that's so dumb i know i i hate the 10 minute delay i hate it
so much yeah by the way everything i say from now on is
going to show up on the stream if when the 10 minutes are i
mean i've already been live anyways you're showing okay cool
okay cool anyway that's crazy you should talk to all those
people it's nice i know it's insane i'm so glad none of us
are live you know what i said all those things about those
people you know that was oh my god i know oh my god if it
goes live thing i just said actually went out to the public
i'll it'll be so over for you we're going to court buddy
yeah it'll be so over especially for you oh wait wait oh i
don't talk man i can't handle confrontation i can't talk
yeah you don't yeah you don't yeah you don't talk yeah i
told him definitely last week was different last week was
different yeah yeah so oh you already lied What else are you
lying about, Whig?
What else are you lying about?
Listen, man.
They were jumping on my friends, bro.
I don't fuck with that.
They were fucking with my dogs.
I like that.
And you just don't like that they're especially fucking with
you.
Yeah, I also hate that.
It's just as much to the other.
I don't worry.
It was all in love.
You know, those guys know I love them.
Those guys know I love them.
Yeah.
Love.
If that's the love that you're giving, to like those people
that oh my god the things wig says off stream is so hello
this is crazy part is you're gonna say all this and still
get a fucking level 10 hype train by the way for those of
you in wigs chat have you guys heard of twitch prime yeah
use it on go to your search type out dokeybird on twitch and
then and then click on that channel and then use that twitch
prime on your favorite streamer i mean me oh no yeah dokey
dokey not me totally not me wait why are you going off
script we planned this we planned this from the start wow my
bad my bad i'm going off scripts i'm trying to win today you
know what i mean everything we did yesterday i'm trying to
do the everything last week i'm trying to do the opposite of
today you're at the igl we just listened to you was that
saying about you wait those zones last week were hard though
they were it was slightly difficult it's because like it's
not run by tempo so he can't control the the circles for us
where is this guy we've seven minutes i'm a bit worried now
i'm definitely worried Yeah, I mean now I feel like he was
hyping it up in the chat so much because he's just not awake
He's just like oh my god Where if we're it was he in your
chat earlier?
Oh, no he was in the it was in the fucking discord though
saying I'm awake.
Let's go try to party.
Oh my god.
Yeah, do you think he took a nap?
No, stop it.
Oh, no, wait wait, wait.
Do you have any do you have any like numbers of like any?
Do you have tempos number?
No, I have no tempos number.
I have no how's number I have no one's number.
Do you have any of the T.S.
Do you have none of the TSM members?
No, I don't at all.
Okay.
I think we might have a problem.
We might have a huge issue.
Did you DM me?
Oh, you did.
Okay, you did.
We might have a problem.
Oh my god, my stream's still not live yet.
Your stream is still not live?
It's been 10 minutes.
I'm not alive.
Oh, my God.
This was Tempo's idea, too.
And he's not awake.
This guy's a fucking idiot, man.
If he's not awake, I will actually lose my mind on him.
Me too.
Because he's the one that's so excited about it every time.
Yeah.
He's the one that's like, yeah, he's the one that's gassing
it up every week.
If he fell back to sleep, I'm never doing this thing again.
There's no shot There's no fucking way I can't believe I
think he actually is asleep Why would he not be online?
No, I refuse to be there We can't get a sub because we
didn't even sign up Anyone to substitute No, he has to be
awake He has to be awake, yes, no I'm not playing this as a
duo We're not playing as a duo Why not?
Wait, it'll be so hard What?
You think we can do?
How far do you think we can?
I think we get past first round.
I didn't listen.
At least we get past first round, you know?
Did he like wake up?
Like wait five minutes, see if he answers.
Like, ah, I didn't say anything.
And just fall back asleep.
Holy fuck, dude.
We're code red right now.
Oh, don't you literally reply?
I was like, let's go.
I'm, oh my God.
Oh, there's the legend himself.
He's awake.
We're in real life.
Oh my God.
Where were you?
We were so nervous about you, man.
we were freaking out this is the group chat i know but we
thought you never appeared oh yeah where did you go we're
all we were like four minutes uh-oh wait i was warming up my
charge rifle earlier we're good oh yeah we're where you did
another lie i've been cleaning for like 30 minutes so what
where were you oh it's i was cleaning oh my god you know you
should have been doing warming up bro what the fuck's going
on you should be warming up okay good good yeah i'm warmed
up now too i'm actually warmed up i'm not warmed up oh yeah
someone here's going crazy uh uh dokey why don't you tell
them what you got yesterday i got a new mouse guys it's so
cute it's like blue oh wait with your with your new pc and
everything no no this was a different mouse it's like a
custom painted g pro i that is super light have you ever
used a g pro i was before yeah yeah my other one's a g pro
but this one's this number two like it's like the other
one's g pro super light this one's g pro super light too so
apparently it's lighter yeah they're they're pretty much the
exact same thing no no they're like three grams lighter is
that is that hashtag ad or what no sponsor me g pro wireless
do you have connections to g pro wireless to logitech yeah i
was actually on funny enough i was on a logitech box oh my
god can you tell them to sponsor i'm actually sponsored by
uh Oh shit, can you tell them to sponsor me too?
Yeah, I'm down against you.
Yeah, all these sponsors.
All I'm saying is, all I'm saying is Turtle Beach today did
tweet they're releasing new products.
And I might, I may or may not know the products are.
What I'm saying?
Hey.
I mean, it might be very, very good.
That's all I'm saying.
I, I do it for, I'll do it for less than he does.
That's crazy.
I'll do it for $10 less than he does.
I'll do it for less money and I'll do it better.
And I'll make sure I'll do better.
That is insane.
Turtle Beach just goes to your chat.
It gives you five subs.
By the way, Turtle Beach, my Twitch is, my business email is
DokiCanRead at gmail.com.
Hit me up.
Hit her up, guys.
Hit her up.
Yeah, hit me up.
Hit the girl up.
Tell me you have the code in her now.
No, it's not out yet.
Is that out?
Okay.
It still says a minute 20.
Nice.
I just want to warm up the whole time.
Where am I?
Where is my game?
Let me inform.
Get on your PC, bro.
What are you doing?
Oh, what are you doing on your phone?
What?
What are you doing on your phone?
Get on your PC.
Wait, that's your phone.
your PC.
Are you on your PC right now?
Yeah.
What's wrong with your fucking mic?
Wait, what's wrong with my mic?
Wait, he's not on your webcam.
He's not on your webcam.
Oh, I was like, I thought he was on his phone.
Way better last week.
That's for sure.
Yeah, that's definitely not a microphone.
I thought, I legitimately thought he was still on his
fucking phone.
Okay.
What?
What now?
All right.
where are we what the fuck what about now uh you sound kind
of the same i think yeah yeah yeah you do sound the same
what the did you do i don't know like my thing is on the
fortune my more my thing is on the fortune cookie i think
plug have you tried plug in and unplugging your way wait
wait wait i think i know what it is i changed my light to
earth wait no yeah this is all set to default oh my god okay
there you go now it's better it's better now yeah you sound
so much better it's so much better i was changing the audio
on my stream and i was like is this better it's the wrong
thing whoops i fell down i'm warming guys i'm warming up
guys with my new mouse guys i'm doing it good she's doing it
guys i'm doing it she's doing it all right i'm live now 10
minutes later let's go live 10 minutes later to go hear this
yeah oh right uh live now wait right now what i swear
lockdown is like oh my gosh i'm gonna hear myself hear
yourself throughout me i hear my no no no through my own
stream oh i still alive i was and I'm still alive.
What?
Everything is fine.
I'm locked in now.
We're so locked in.
You guys can't hear anything like background noise from me,
right?
Nope.
No, you're good.
Nope, we're so good.
Wait, what?
We're so locked.
Yeah, we're so locked right now.
Very locked.
When is TSM playing right now?
Oh, yeah.
Or what?
Oh, are we?
TSM We should actually do TSM after this.
It'll be funny We should be TSM every time TSM CC Make them
a fake name like we're TSM white.
Oh Wait, that's such a good idea.
People are like bro.
Are they actually son of TSM?
We just died.
Yes, we just died now.
Yeah, that's us.
We're too.
We should change.
We should make a club Wait, are you guys on clans right now?
Are you guys in any clans?
How do you join a clan?
The fucking groups were the calls.
Yeah.
Didn't they get rid of some club?
Should we do a TSM club?
Yeah, yeah, we should do a TSM club.
Did they get rid of clubs?
Wait, no they didn't.
Why would they get rid of the best thing ever?
You got rid of clubs.
When did it- The best thing ever, that shit sucked.
It was so useless.
Yeah, but what the fuck, it's not useless to me.
It is.
It's overall just useless in general.
It's not useless to me.
My opinion is matter.
Do they actually?
I might have actually.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
What if guys guys when we wait we had to name change
remember?
Oh my god.
We did not do that.
No, I can't do that now.
I'm my shit's gonna get so yoinked so fast Wait, oh But
don't you have steam?
Yeah, you can just change it on steam.
You can't do any shit on steam though.
What the fuck is you?
Yeah, they got they got rid of it.
They got rid of that thing.
That's why I do so bad all the time
Oh shit!
And that's my number one issue, huh?
What do you mean you don't?
I play on EA app.
You mean?
I'm an EA stand.
Wait, that doesn't matter.
We're still playing an EA game.
I'm an EA con your sore.
It actually feels better for controller on this.
I'm not even kidding.
I don't know why.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
You were like, we're gonna name change.
and everything no it's not placebo bro trust me you guys
should play road today and just try it watch yeah we are oh
my god one two three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve twelve teams there's 13 teams oh thank god
guys we don't get past this oh wait that gives us what if we
okay first game we run at teams we fight there's no way we'd
lose right yeah yeah we just you just oh yeah okay the only
the only name i recognize here is shops who's shop oh wait
shops and flake are they in the same team no that is they're
on two different teams they play a lot of they play a lot of
uh like cc i want to say they played like cc shit okay bro
league was still going on gotcha is that bad good bad right
that means we have two teams that are good that are pretty
solid that means we have two teams that we can bait into all
the other teams to just kill them you're so smart buddy all
right so are we okay first game okay how about first game we
don't run at teams just to just to gauge how it's gonna be
like and then after we figure out the skill level we can
decide if we're gonna be little rats or if we're gonna be
you know on gaming i mean listen i'm down i mean listen okay
so what do we want to play that first game um well i'm on
bloodhound right now i don't even know okay you can put you
can put blood we're on the world's edge oh i'm oh world's
edge nice or what sure where do you want to play fuse first
game girls go caustic the streak i'm let's i just want to
want to know right now that the streak i'm drinking is
absolutely horrible beacons guys i'm so locked in now i feel
like you're lying to me guys no i'm so locked in i'm like oh
why why i'm doing my scans i'm shooting
It's already better than last week.
Yeah, that's already better.
Yeah, I didn't do any of those things.
I barely shot my gun.
To be fair, I went a lot of close range.
I did a lot of close range guns.
Because I assume we'd be fighting more instead of, you know.
You think we're going to fight more?
I don't know.
I was told that round one would be so easy.
And then so I thought that I'll be fighting more, you know.
Well, that's the problem here, though.
That's the problem is that it is easy.
It's just not really for us.
you know yeah apparently it is the easiest round but there
is no easy round for us guys we're facing adversity every
step of the way like every step for you it's an uphill
battle every every round for us no matter what that's like a
little unfortunate not gonna lie that's a little sad i love
that though dokey get in wait we have the code oh yeah code
job It's okay.
It's okay.
We're locked.
It's all right.
All right.
Okay.
Give me a...
I won.
All right.
Now I'm ready.
I literally just won my control game.
Okay.
Nice.
That means we're going to win the day.
Yeah, yeah.
That's true.
Remember, if we win our control game, it means we win.
Guys, we have to win at least one game today.
Yeah.
Like, at least... Even if we go out second round again, can
we at least win one game today?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I think about how exciting that is.
best round of one will be this first game i can't promise
anything throw everyone off i gotta oh my god guys guys i
guys i have news yeah guys wait did the temple leave wait
the temple leave already temple are you here oh no okay wait
i need yeah i need temple to be here before i can say it
guys it's like really big news yeah yeah it's huge news i
feel like you're just lying so
for tempo if it's not big news this guy is 100k channel
points my channel a hug oh my god we're gonna do 100k it's
so fun every time i come in these lobbies everyone's just
like oh what's up dude i'm like dude let's go that's the
only thrill i get out of this man if only somebody
remembered to do something dude wait wait wait wait are we
fucked man what are we playing where are we landing guys i
don't know you're the igl i just yeah i don't know i know
but i i mean i'm just i'm an indecisive igl i'm an
unconscious that's like that's not that's the worst kind of
igl that's why i stopped being an igl i'm like yeah i think
i think this is right guys all right um is anyone lava i
mean there's gonna be answers gonna be there's no way we
okay oh my Okay, here's my big news guys.
Here's my big news.
I'm on the level four hype train right now on Twitch on
Twitch They're not even streaming me
That's the most used shit I've heard in my life.
Oh My god, it's level five now It's level five.
Hey guys, you know I'm live guys You can literally give me
subs and you get a reaction now you can literally give me
subs and i'll give you a reaction you have no mods on here
on youtube that's crazy my name is crazy i like tempo typed
in my chat uh follow for follow you know you got no you got
you got no you got no mods sucker yes we do mod ben is full
oh i have a mod your channel's not live you got no mods on
you're i don't know i think you did multi-cast you don't do
multicast no i don't do multitask because i don't i don't
want to split the viewership and also have two chats to
worry about okay yeah that's true because did you get one
split your viewership though huh did you get one split your
viewership i heard like a lot of people on youtube that's
fair yeah i think so um and also like uh fucking fucking
tempo also like i just feel like it's just too much to work
to like handle two chats at the same time or rather just
like handle one one chat that's valid yeah oh my god thank
you guys thank you for all the gifted subs on twitch hi
level six oh my god you guys shouldn't have wait wait wait
you guys know where we're going no where are we going oh
well i don't know wait do we not claim anything no i didn't
create a single thing no i was waiting for tempo to claim
something oh i just bro i just trust you all right is there
any any place you want to go like siphon i just typed siphon
so i said wait i don't know if anyone's there wait what's
your hype train record i have no idea actually okay here's
how you can find it you go how do you check it how you check
it okay you okay let me how because you're gonna make it a
gold of b-bine you little i should just type that can we
break our record Can we break WIG's record?
It's not easy to use to get that train up.
All right, how to look up a hype train record.
Okay, how to know your hype train is activated.
How do you know your hype train record?
I don't think there's a...
I don't think there's anything that tells you.
I'm not sure either.
What is...
How to figure out your hype train record.
No, no, no, we're live.
Oh my god, we're in game, we're in game.
Oh shit, okay.
Sorry, this one, this thing was more important.
I got my bot in Doki's channel.
It's giving my, my channel, so we're good.
All right, are you playing Fuse or Kostak?
Okay, Kostak, cool.
All right, I'm gonna do Bloodhound or Bang.
Play Blood, play Blood, play Blood.
Okay, okay.
Are you cool on blood?
Yeah, I'm cool on blood.
I practiced blood yesterday.
Okay.
Don't worry.
guys we're very locked in right now yes i'm gonna play i'm
gonna play a valve for the rotates in all right i believe in
us me too i believe in us too like what's the worst that
could happen nothing nothing's the worst thing that could
happen never anything what's the what's the worst that could
happen so backup plan backup plan yeah if someone goes
siphon we either go tree or launch site because they both
they both have the thingy too yeah okay So I'm down.
Yeah.
If someone just decides to come save in.
I feel like someone's going to be both, but we'll see.
I'm trusting you with the flight here too, buddy.
It's all you, man.
Trusting all of you.
I'm trusting both of you because I just tapped out.
I can fly like Evan.
I just tapped out.
Wait, wait.
Why does it look like there's two teams right beside us?
I don't know.
On our right side.
No, we're good.
We're good.
They're not coming here.
I don't think.
Oh, shit.
Yo, we're mission.
Go left.
Exactly what Evan taught me.
All right.
I blame him.
We're good.
There's no one here.
There's no here.
We're good.
Is this how they won?
Jesus Christmas.
What a start.
Wow.
Guys, I don't know.
I don't know.
Guys, I have two destructor rounds.
You guys keep in the middle.
We have both beacons.
This is perfect, guys.
At first I thought like, maybe maybe we're gonna do this.
Now I don't know after that.
No,
I'm more locked in.
I'm more locked in today than I was last week.
I'll tell you how much.
what the happened last week what the you were lucky
you're on team here guys we were going to continue about it
yeah but you weren't thinking about the team when you
weren't locked in
bitch yeah that's my that's all me that's my bad there's a
havoc here if anyone wants it i'm volt lomba i'm actually
kind of solid right now i'm both uh oh yo we got we got a
staggy yeah we can go fast too if we need as well all right
i'm at six x does anyone want the six x no i'm good where's
the where's the thing yeah the the beacon no the uh the the
i dropped a charge rifle are you okay are you evil cash he's
talking about the evil cash oh yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna go
scan my brain just turned off i'm just gonna scan the people
temple i i uh i paid the charge rifle do you have one
already no okay it's in this building it's the clearly the
first floor i'm not using it i'm going to get the evo cash
if i die for it just run away all right that's fine we can
we cannot craft you but that's fine i have two disruptor
rounds does anyone have an alternator?
No.
Nope.
No, sir.
I'm going to do the thing.
Where do we go?
We're going to go.
We're going to straight to stacks for sure.
Let's give me a stack then, Gabe.
Okay, we're coming over to you.
Yeah, we'll just go from like, we'll just go over here.
Just go towards this balloon.
The right side.
All right.
We should be getting going.
I'm beside you, a wig.
Why am I too low?
I can't really hear it.
Have you ever considered turning up the volume yeah actually
i was just thinking that right now yeah i'm just saying like
if that's a problem you could you know there's a very easy
solution there's only one team at stacks right now yeah i
mean that's so crazy though why i mean i guess because i
mean we could take this fight if we wanted to yeah not
against it let's see then we die 13th which is first yeah
get one point ready guys all right where do we go where do
we go what do you mean already Well, oh, you're going first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, guys.
We'll go here, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
The bloodhound will go first, scan, and then die.
Yeah, and you scan?
There we go.
You're going to scan?
Where are you going?
I can't scan when I'm in the air.
What do you mean?
What kind of flying was that?
I was scared.
I didn't want to have cover.
Very good.
I was so scared.
Oh, God, I'm very bad.
All right, come here.
Come to me.
Three, two, two.
Where's the way for a tab?
Oh, nice slide.
Okay, we don't need a way for him.
Are we grabbing like this thingy?
No.
Just come here.
And then we'll grab it if we're like able to.
Oh, look, people.
They're going mod, which I don't agree with.
I don't know.
Just play from here.
Oh, yeah.
We can scan the people beacon and I can scan the beacon
beacon.
I don't know if it's safe to scan.
Is it safe to scan?
Yo, someone else landed.
Oh, they're in the other way.
I'm scanning.
We're good.
Oh, they did it.
Okay, okay.
We just played from here, I think.
I don't know if it's going to pull back side, but I'd rather
be up here for the
Valkyldyldyldyldyldyldyldyldyldyldyldyldy.
Who's going to look at this team over there?
I'll look over there.
I'm just going to look everywhere, to be honest.
I have a long bow.
Let's get some shots.
We're brewing, like, I hope they don't shoot me in the back.
You guys need bats?
Awkward.
I do.
I'm zero.
I'm just two.
Yeah, take that other one.
Let's tell what he's all of them.
No, no, no.
I don't have, if you guys find more steel cells, let me
know.
I only have like five.
Oh, I got you.
I can give you some for sure.
I'm just going to get more ammo.
Oh, they're going to fucking take your shit.
I dropped four down here.
Why don't they get them?
The blowbow doesn't grab them.
I don't think they will.
Oh, if they grab it, we run at them.
Yeah, I agree.
OK, that sounds like a terrible idea.
That's a great idea.
I'm down.
Fuck those guys.
They kick my loot, bro.
We get after it.
I hate motherfuckers who steal loot.
I'm taking a hundred shots of a longbow here.
I steal loot.
Do you hate me?
Yeah.
Wow.
No hesitation, yeah.
Very, very much.
Wait, wait, wait.
Try and grab the evo.
No one's going to kill you right now.
Yeah, yeah, try, try, try.
I bet you no one's going to kill you.
All right, if I die, let me know.
I bet you.
I bet you, like, one gifted sub.
Okay.
Well, I'm already here.
I didn't really hesitate.
A whole one gifted sub that no one's going to kill you.
And then if you live, you got to give me one sub.
How does that work?
Because it's a bet, you know?
I want the bet.
I'm going to just die.
i won the bet someone kill me someone kill me oh we're
vibing we're so good guys look at our lock we're so loved
yeah we got our zone playing man yeah there's actually the
highlight of my week sadly every time the challenges yeah
what are you gonna do after this weekend did you watch the
fucking finals of the last cc and this is the highlight i
know and the whole time i was like damn we could it could
have been us we could have one oh my charge rifle oh my gosh
i don't have a charge rifle yet i paid the charge rifle for
you what happened there's one downstairs one downstairs i
think third floor or second floor i'm not sure which one i'm
in let's go revenge smoked whoa i'm trying to slap me i was
nuts oh my gosh i can't stand up there anymore where's that
from okay front side yeah this side here i'll stand the back
there that's where they are it was not on third floor they
broke your barrels temple by the way i'll break their face
whoa in game bro in game bro you don't want to get twitch oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah bro because i would definitely report
you i found it get your subs from my train no does someone
need that what the heavy mag no i already have a purple
wrong this guy's just so annoying i need to find a better
scope now i found my charge rifle well good luck with that
yeah good luck with though bro i don't think guys my eyes
aren't working yet i would just keep scanning oh no not this
again i feel like my eyes i like i see the frames but my
eyes yeah they're a little they're a little half right now
they're not fully open yet not having eyes yet it's not good
for me that's why i scan that's why i scan some yeah so you
can see bright orange things oh god yeah i have no sniper i
have a bunch here oh that'd be 16.
you drop where at her how many bros oh my god guys i dropped
that and another bat okay that's me found some loot whoa
where are they shooting us from oh my god God, I knocked
this kid all in.
Oh my God, get fucking shit on.
Anyway, how much meds did you waste for that knock?
Not that many actually, only one Phoenix so far.
Oh nice, that's good.
I'm gonna get purple.
Do you think I can scan this?
I'm gonna do it.
You knocked him, he's gonna be, they're so scared.
Yeah, they're scared now.
They think I'm cheating.
I said, I get my purple guys.
Oh nice.
Okay.
There is two.
Two teams.
That doesn't have, these teams are slowly rotating in.
Yeah, we're good right now.
vibe but we just play here whoa you missed every shot is he
on the roof yeah oh that was really bad i was looking at the
map yeah that's pretty bad yeah he's still still he still
missed wow if that team over there is higher rank than us
then there's a problem there's a problem in the system with
apex judges there's a problem there's a big issue actually
oh my god we're at level 10 we're gonna break wings record
i'm so proud of you guys all right thanks guys so much guys
i'm so proud of you guys i take you guys thank you guys
don't worry wig is not taking any cut of this yeah no i
should where's my igl pay at which is crazy which igl pay if
we get past round two i'm sorry the pay is that in our
contract if we get past round two i'm gonna get paid yeah
you get paid well i don't say i'm not getting paid anytime
soon guys gonna be looking for a job real quick is your job
now you can't break this contract or you'll have to pay me a
million dollars
they are aren't they throwing it no i'm i'm just oh hey
there's a watson team underneath us team 10 eliminated
that's not us guys that's not us not us can we just waste
grenade on those guys from there can i scan the people i can
only scan it once right even if it's a new ring no i think
per round can't you per ring right i'm not sure i should
don't remember it's bad that i don't know that yeah i can't
only once okay only once you how many how many fucking games
what the fuck i'm dead like what the fuck all right i'm
running back no there's nobody near you where i just get
shot from then what the that you get shot i thought that
sounded on me okay clearly wigs ears aren't working that is
why you're scared east Whig's ears are not working.
No, wait, wait.
Is someone in that building?
It doesn't have to be.
Yeah, they are.
Down there.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to scan you for a second.
They were definitely in there before.
Tempo, what the fuck are you jumping on there?
Tempo, what the fuck are you doing?
They're to our left.
I found a 4 to 8x.
Oh my god, that 4x8 though.
There's a team right here running.
Don't worry, can't catch me.
There's a team over behind this rock, by the way.
Oh, I got shoved in the southwest.
There's a team in this building southwest.
I got 4x8 now.
Everyone's dead.
Nice.
Oh, I just got knocked from so far away.
Can you rest?
He rest.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Run away, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Res now, don't worry.
Nobody is going to show up.
Anyone have a Phoenix kit?
X-U1 or no?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I only have shield cells.
They just literally all three shot me.
I just got repeater charge rifles.
Where are they shooting from?
Like, all the way from the dome, the team that he knocked
at, they're very mad about now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're really mad.
I don't have I just have like three shield cells, but I do
have two bats, so yeah, I'm fine There's team poor poor
laying right now.
Oh, I'm gonna be behind our during the RV I see that.
Oh my god.
It's your favorite spot.
Yeah, that's about such a nice What do you mean?
We got like two second places from that It should have
happened though if we're being honest Over here by the way,
I'm running away.
I'm trying to shoot them right now.
I'm hitting.
I cracked them.
I cracked two I cracked three
I still fuck with you up.
One shot.
I hope.
Can I actually get the knock?
Full kill?
I don't think so.
No.
They have room behind the thing.
That sucks.
Barely though.
That blows.
Good knock though.
Yeah, good knock.
I helped him, by the way.
Yeah, you did.
Yeah, for sure.
They're dying up there four time bow.
You're actually a beast for that.
They're getting ran out now.
You're a beast.
Oh.
my god oh yeah they're gonna say oh no i missed i'm so much
more warmed up this week than i was last week i'm actually
hitting shots right now which is crazy wait what does that
mean last week last week i did horrible i did horrible guys
we're top 10 we practically qualified i keep wall jumping it
sounds really good for us by the way oh we're chilling okay
nice yeah one two three what's in the pack oh wingman i need
to keep scanning these packs you guys got our If I forget
his team had big monies coming to teams like next to us
anymore.
Yeah, we're good right now They're only I think they're only
on the southwest side.
Yeah, I think they went this way Ash TP Where did they?
Oh, I see it No, it's not for him Why does it take it still
now?
There he is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah I gotta reload.
I can't see what I'm gonna look waiting for him to move.
He's not gonna move Yep, I'm watching him 25 again.
I'm just gonna keep watching him.
Me too.
All right direction watch him and then just make sure you
can never clock yeah that's what i'm literally doing right
now i'm not what i'm calling i think there's a team
underneath us there's people underneath us now yeah there's
like here they directly underneath us too is that on us
we're fine right now we're fine can you have enough barrels
down right somewhere you're getting okay yeah yeah yeah i'm
still watching that corner i am too there's a there's a team
fighting over here he's still there bro you're nice he's
getting nice he's getting shot someone else i was I was
meantime, but I am for 96.
Oh my god, okay.
I heard that thing, and then I turned around.
It was just you.
Oh, you're good.
He's a wraith.
Why isn't he queuing up?
The one I just cracked was a wraith, wasn't it?
Well, I mean, if he's not queuing up, I don't think it's a
wraith anymore.
If he's not queuing up.
Oh, he went up, he went up.
It wasn't a wraith.
There's a team.
Yeah, it was.
Oh, then why the fuck did he not queue?
I don't know.
What a fucking idiot.
Yeah, what an idiot.
I'm not really sure.
Why would he pick wraith?
Yeah.
They're just chewing.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
On me, on me, on me, on me!
On me!
That's shithole!
What the fucking audio was not...
Bruh.
There's no way.
You guys are down below, you guys are on this.
No, I'm down below.
I'm down below, I'm down below.
Tell you what, play what, play, play, play.
I have to get down.
Are you fucking kidding me?
If you don't want to drop first floor, you can.
It's up to you.
Throw the caustic barrel.
Oh, they got the caustic.
You guys can come first floor if you want, it's up to you.
Are they on first floor?
No, no, they're not.
they're never gonna drop down and hit dead stick and fight
you though nice probably tempo jump down already dokey oh no
no no i'm gonna stay here for a bit no no no no no audio bro
again nope this is this is why these kids this is this is
why i didn't jump down no it doesn't matter though we were
dead you guys are gonna get sent on the darkness yeah you're
so lucky don't you live oh where is that audio are you
kidding me
Evacking oh no, they're sending you Oh, if you just drop
down the first four you can grab both our banners and res us
now No way there's no way there's no way If you're not res
us, do not even think about resing us Wow, that audio is
fucking pog by the way Oh, sick Dokey, you can res us trust
me No fucking way, I'm not resing you guys Put your life,
put your life Don't listen to that guy, man Plug us in, plug
us in Where, plug you where Wait, you're gonna stand this
white side You got this, bro, you got this enlighten me
nowhere nowhere nowhere nowhere this guy's an idiot in the
zone i think you craft a battery here imagine i don't know i
already have bad bat i'll have one bat dude i can't believe
they just three men took a zip line i'm so sad i mean they
lived is it really a throw if they didn't oh no it wasn't a
bad play that was a good play but i just i thought i didn't
know what floor they were on underneath this i thought we
had first floor on us oh oh i know they're right underneath
us seven points for sure yeah yeah yeah three go for it
you're good go to your day okay we're i mean there's no way
we just don't qual so we're fine but yeah i mean i think we
probably still need a few kills here or there oh yeah we'll
be fine i'm not right about it bro we're no way we get top
seven every game should we get three other games to make up
for it that is insane though bro i cannot believe that they
actually just three minutes i mean i was blind there was no
audio at the last second that was wait was the zip line
going now i told dokey to scan underneath this i don't think
she did i i told her the other way no no from the roof to
the no or something no it was the zip line on the floor
underneath us i asked dokey if she can scan underneath this
i don't think she did i thought they were on the first floor
not the run underneath us but i knew they're underneath us
right now i would have told you to put barrels on the this
is right now well there was one barrel and no yeah totally i
just it just sucks three men took it unfortunate how's your
six teams alive here i don't know it's pretty i mean it's
pretty easy sound to live it sucks
that blows man three fucking man sent a zip we can we can
get revenge next game oh yeah
Okay, I'm gonna use the Washington to it.
I'll be right back.
Oh, man.
Yo, yo, yo.
Hey.
That could have been us.
Hell no.
This could have been us.
Not a chance.
winning this not losing this one day three oh my god that
could have been us right there we could have been that team
with second place i can't believe that i didn't hear any i
had no idea they're on the floor underneath us bro i cannot
believe that there's three men took a zip on me that is so
unfortunate crazy parties almost arrived too yeah you almost
wait a minute you could have helped you there too yeah it
sucks it was just so fast you know what's fucked up what's
up i've been timed out for one hour where my chat i wonder
where are you In my chat?
No, in my chat because he kept advertising his own channel
on my fucking online chat.
Good, Tom.
It's good for you.
I look over and I'm like, what the fuck?
All right, what place we have?
We're going to be in like, what, like ninth place now?
That's mean.
All right, we got to make a new lobby, right?
Yeah, there's video code.
Yeah, yeah, most likely.
Yeah, it's snowing.
All right.
Oh, wow.
Fuck me, man.
What's wrong?
I can't believe I've got three man shantons.
It's all right.
It's because it's because someone didn't change their name.
Well, honestly, it's probably the longbow charge label.
That's a clear indicator.
All right.
We're in seven.
All I'm saying is if somebody changed their name.
I don't know.
My god.
Maybe I should have made a just nice rigged thief.
You know, seven plays.
We just need to have good consistent games.
It would be so sad if this is the fucking week we get
knocked out first round.
And we get the easiest.
Oh, they imagine.
Jesus.
First round would be really bad.
Technically, this is like better.
Technically, this is supposed to be easier.
year for us to see no no first round is harder for us round
two is gonna be the easiest round three yeah yeah round
three will be around two will be normal so yeah i meant like
i meant like for this this this this round one should be
easier than last week's round one so it'll be very fucking
awkward if you know we did not make it through yeah that'll
be so awkward we are in oh awkward we're in seven seven oh
yeah yeah all right we're fine yeah we're so good guys
literally we have to like actually be the worst to knock
wall and like no offense like we're bad we're not what if
what if 11 12 and 13 are watching your stream right now huh
yeah yeah we got a lot of work somebody okay 11 12th and
13th place are watching your stream and they just feel sad
because you called them the worst in the game yeah that's
pretty up yeah i thought i thought you were a nice i thought
you were a nice person yeah what happened you've changed bro
you fucking changed he started he started competing and then
he changed yeah you used to be a nice guy
bro uh codes up codes up nice where is it discord oh okay i
see right back i'm back i'm back oh you were not ghosting us
you were just not here we said good things about you and
then you didn't respond back we said good things about you
and then you didn't respond back and then we got sad i got a
monster guys i can't believe it i stole it from no go i'm
shit i'm getting bullied just like i was last year what were
we talking about you changed man there's no difference
there's no difference we were we were saying like the nicest
things ever about you and then you just disappeared on us
and then now we take this indecisive i gel there's just so
much whoa why are you so harsh on yourself bro we're talking
bro dude why are you so mean yourself bro the first step is
acknowledging that you matter after berating me for like
nine hours dude why are you so tough on yourself man yeah
Dan, what the fuck?
Where's your self-esteem?
Yeah, where are you at, bro?
What's going on?
Yeah.
How's that confidence up?
You little shithead?
Too bad you don't have a chat to the fact checkers.
Not now.
In 10 minutes, I will.
You can wait 10 minutes for it.
Yeah, in 10 minutes.
But you don't even know where that's supposed to be about.
Wiggin' tempo is so serious.
Doki shoots in the air.
Cracked four.
What?
She missed like 75 shots and she's like cracked three.
Oh my god.
I watched the team she was shooting.
I was hitting them and she hit zero shots.
I watched it all happen in front of me, dude.
I know, no, no, they were, it was cracked.
You know that.
You don't have the POV on my screen.
Yeah, I'll get it in 10 minutes.
10 minutes.
I'm pretty sure jokes on you.
There's no rewind on my screen.
stream you gotta wait until the bots over delete delete spot
you can't see anything i hit them all what do you mean i hit
all of them you guys just don't understand my chat my chat's
just spamming audio because i just got fucking rocked in the
game i actually shit myself i can't be those yeah i actually
i did not know there was a zip there i'm gonna be honest bro
i knew the zip was there but I just had no idea they're the
floor underneath us.
That's my bad.
I didn't know that either.
You're the bloodhound man.
I didn't scan there.
I didn't know.
I didn't have my scan.
Bro, we should have, like, those tag names.
You see those people at the AES9?
You know, do you see those?
Oh, my God.
Before, let's do that.
For the third game, let's all change our name to TSM
underscore.
Oh, my God.
It's so funny.
And then people are like, people on the competitive, like,
apex, right?
That's great.
We got signed to TSN.
Wait, did you see the post about us like a couple weeks ago
when we first announced it?
They were like, this team's going to do awful.
If you all thought we were playing like these serious
styles, like dude, there's no way people think we're
serious.
Dude, what the fuck?
I mean, who's going to, they're like, who's going to IGL?
Like, I understand how this team thinks they're going to do
well.
I'm like, bro, why are they participating?
They're not going to win.
They're going to throw it.
I remember I saw someone tweeted something like, these
people are making fun of the competitive integrity of TSN.
Yeah, we are yes, we are They're not gonna take it
seriously.
Why are they joining the CC?
Yeah, that just proves that if we do better than you then
what the fuck?
What are you doing?
Yeah, what the fuck are you doing?
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah, the last time I touched a- okay, that's- I know I
played Apex yesterday.
The last time I touched Apex competitive was the last- You
played Apex yesterday?
Yeah.
Why are you so bad today?
a new mouse
why are you so why are you so shit today what the fuck man
I'm literally on a new mouse like what the fuck do you want
from me oh fuck dude three grams difference that actually a
big difference in mice yeah oh actually I don't know I think
I'm doing pretty alright I'm doing pretty okay with the
three grams of no you did great yeah Yeah, they both feel
exact.
I mean, yeah, three grams of really throw off my gameplay
for sure.
No, no, throw mine off.
She's right.
No, did you guys not see the four people I cracked?
No, no, I actually didn't see those people.
I really got to watch her back.
Look at my POV.
I cracked like four to five people and then like nobody
cared.
I'm so, so, oh wow, I'm so sorry.
No, no, not you making me feel bad about a crack that didn't
happen.
care yeah no one appreciates me all right wait who's going
middle someone go middle i'm going yeah i got middle i got
middle yeah i need the thing yeah you're good you're good oh
we got hot drop wow wow wow give me a golden charge rifle
okay that's asking a lot i hope we find that for you buddy
yeah like i can only imagine how big your smile would be
picking that thing up that's enough to make me want to give
you one a big golden stick all right whoa Whoa.
Big golden what now?
You called it a big golden stick.
Uh, here's a 3x if anyone needs it.
I'll actually take that.
We won't take it over.
Where's the zone now?
Let's see.
Anyone finds a vault and not use it?
Let me know.
There was a vault in my room somewhere.
Oh, I almost got run over by the...
Guys, I drank some coffee now.
I'm so locked in.
My eyes are a little bit more open now.
Ooh, I got a blue helmet here for anybody.
Oh, I was muted.
Anyone need a gold heavy mag?
Uh, yeah.
Me, me, me, me.
I'll bring it over to you.
Me, me, me, me, me.
Backpack.
Oh, my God, there's another...
Is someone taking that gold energy mag or now?
If they are, it's dead.
Because I just found a ball.
Me, me, me, me, me.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Oh, nice.
All right, where's the EVO cache?
I'll get the EVO cache just next to me.
Yeah, you're good.
And then I'll scan the people scanner.
There's a purple helmet.
Oh, here.
That'd be great.
Is that a charge rifle?
No, I haven't found a single charge rifle.
I haven't seen one either, buddy.
I know it's tough for you out here, bud.
I know.
Where you can deal with your life when you don't have your
charge rifle.
I have all the stuff for a charge rifle.
I just don't have the charge rifle.
Wait, I found it.
Oh, nice.
I'm trying to find him.
He found it.
Um, okay.
That's gonna be a Skyhook zone for sure, obviously.
I think it's gonna pull probably towards like the back of
Skyhook around that area.
We had zero kills last game?
Yeah.
Seven, seven, seven.
Seven plays though.
We had zero kills?
Oh, kill smells.
Don't even matter.
Oh my God.
I cracked all those people just for zero kills.
Just to get nothing out of this.
Now, how would people know I actually cracked them if you
guys didn't?
Yeah, I think that actually might be our fault.
Wait, I got a golden ball here.
I'm going to scan people.
Golden balls.
Oh, I got a gold knockdown.
Holy shit.
Okay.
We had to rotate.
Whoa.
Yeah, no, we should definitely leave.
Okay.
So we grab this.
I have the gold mag for you too, Doki, by the way.
Or what?
Oh, the heavy.
Okay.
No, no, no.
Oh, I almost fucking landed on the lava.
Okay.
You're good.
rotate it we could technically have a free rotate if we just
go fast no we gotta we gotta grab that one and then we gotta
grab that one and then we gotta grab that one i think we're
gonna skip that and we're gonna go through fragment get that
one instead and then go through whatever it is here come
here we're gonna i'm here oh eva fuck that balloon let's go
i'm here belong all right we're gonna go through fragment
then we're gonna go to grandmas and blue bins yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the goal we should be able to hit this rotate
pretty clean i don't think it was Carol.
Wee.
I'm waiting for the coffee to set in.
You're good.
We're going to go to that evo cash and fragment, right?
All right.
That's the goal here.
Okay.
We'll all run together.
We're fine.
There's going to be no one in there.
And then we're going to go to boobin.
She's over here.
And get this one.
And then people stand and then valkalty into this zone.
Oh my God.
You're so smart wig.
This is why you're on IGL.
God.
He has a plan.
Wait.
That's a gold mask over there.
I do.
You want it here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Drop it up here.
Actually, drop it up here.
Pay it last for you?
No, it's fine.
I got it.
There you go.
Yay.
See, my idea cares.
I do.
I care so much about you guys.
Don't believe any of those people that said you don't care.
Don't believe like all the people in my chat saying that
you're horrible, man.
They were wrong about you.
They were so right.
They're so wrong about you.
Now I know.
Yeah, you just get me never believed in those haters All
right, let's keep walking up.
We're gonna go that blue bit to get that evo cast again We
let's do it.
I'm also gonna get rid of this.
I don't know if I want to one or two.
I'm dropping it No, I don't need it.
I need no one around to be right guys.
No, we're good Oh, I'll get the two times actually sure no
we're not Yeah, scamming the beacon up there.
It's okay.
That's okay They should rotate out of like a way.
They shouldn't find us here.
Yeah, because they're like, oh, I'm scared.
Woo, people!
I don't know what they're thinking.
What else would we be thinking of?
Well, they might not think it's us, so they might actually
be scared.
Yeah, they'll be like, ooh, I'm scared.
Let's keep it sort of.
Okay.
That's ready.
Keep on moving.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm going to get this Evo cache.
Then we're going to go people scan like they just did, then
rotate it into the sky.
Oh, and then I can charge rifle, everyone.
Yeah, when we get in the sky.
Yeah, we hit about go to in there too.
Oh, yeah, we get right here.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, that sounds juicy right there.
I love juicy.
Whoa, whoa.
Whoa, this is like Christian friendly stream.
Like, oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
They're not riding us, right?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, you scanned already not the building.
Yeah, yeah.
No, we didn't need to build the anyway.
There's no way.
Oh, God.
Oh god, they might be in here.
There's no way.
Oh god.
They left.
They left 60 seconds ago.
Okay, nice.
See you guys.
I walked through it.
I walked through the whole living and Dougie's like, yeah,
we'll just scan that real quick.
We're fine.
Let's see.
What are you so worried about?
You're so paranoid.
What the fuck are you two teams doing?
The team already top sky, but uh, we push them off top sky.
Um, they may not be in there.
Come on, come over to me.
Yeah, I'll be in like my hair.
We're gonna hit the alcohol.
They might not be in the top area They might be on the
bottom.
They're not in the top.
Do we just play one of these buildings or if they are in the
top?
Yeah Yeah, yeah, they are the top.
They are there there there.
Darcia.
Yeah, we're just gonna go.
We're just gonna go four store here Which one this one?
Yeah, four store here.
Okay, I'll scan We should be fine.
I'll be it was on here Yeah, there's nobody.
I don't need a scan then.
Yeah, we can all just rotate out if we need to I'm just
gonna go if we if the zone goes towards that diner side more
over here diner on her right and then just keep walking
through okay oh basically if the zone keeps pointing the
right over here which i'm not sure it's gonna we're gonna
just rotate down through these diners and just go for the
first all right i'm the same now you're good you're good
you're good you're good i'm paying attention i'm paying
attention sorry i couldn't multitask his tempo was getting
shot no it's okay it's scary yeah yeah i was worried because
he was on the roof yeah and i was i was getting deja vu he
scares me the most when he's getting shot we're being honest
yeah honestly when he gets shot when he's getting shot he's
most likely might die that's that's why i'm not i'm not on a
uh i'm in a room i'm not on a roof so we're good that's true
you're You're really, you're, and I think your arch nemesis
is a, is a roof.
What are you shot at here?
Oh, he's like, three times if it wants that.
I want to fucking get rid.
Is that a fucking Watson thing?
Good barrels down below tempo.
Okay.
Oh my God, it's being proactive.
Look at you, bud.
It's actually good barrels too.
Let's fucking go, man.
Actually good barrels down.
What a fucking like compliment slap.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Tell me what up.
Who was it, dude?
Little shit.
Oh, no.
They had some people on the roof.
They are on the rampart.
They touched and it was not fun.
Oh, my God, bro.
Their setup is crazy scary.
They're diabolical over there.
I can only shoot this team now because the other team has a
bloody rampart.
Yeah, I'm scared of that team.
Not going to lie.
Yeah, it's like a team that we can't even do anything
against.
Yeah.
I'm scared.
I don't even want to fucking peek that shit.
Does someone want my charge rifle after?
Oh, nope.
I already got purple.
Graber over there?
Can I get that, Graber?
That's really far.
That's really close to this team.
I know, but fuck me.
Do it.
No, I can't.
If I die, then we are so fucked.
Okay, yeah, don't do it.
Don't do it.
No, respond.
I mean, you can get the beacon, but you can't.
You can't have a banner though.
It's just chalked.
Shoot, fuck off, charge rifle guy.
I'm just gonna hang out here.
I have a 55.
I got my purple up now too, which is good.
How did you get your purple?
I scanned a package and then I got a shot.
Oh, I need like 50 shots.
I don't know who to shoot at because it's just that team and
then the team, the rampart team.
There's like no one else for me to shoot at.
I'm gonna chug another.
I'm gonna chug this coffee.
I said that kid 106 and I knocked this kid?
No, he's not picking me, bitch.
Oh, bitch.
No.
Okay.
Let's try and get this one shot in for that 50.
Come on.
Somebody peek.
Somebody open that door.
Just think about me for a sec, team.
All right, let's see where the sound's going.
All right, well, I think I kind of want to move right, but I
don't know.
I think we just stay here for right now.
Oh, my God.
I'm literally five.
I'm five away.
Is there any way to get under these guys on the roof?
In the middle?
I don't think so, right?
Under these?
Oh, in the middle.
Yeah.
Without dying, I don't know if we could right now.
It may be could, honestly.
It just depends.
I just have no... We have no smokes, which sucks.
Yeah, we only have the scans.
Yeah.
And there's nobody.
There's no one on there?
They left?
What?
Which one?
The middle.
You scanned the middle.
You didn't get anything.
No, they're there.
They're there.
I just didn't...
I'm going on a zip somewhere?
I did not hit...
My rage wasn't in the middle.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's okay.
I'm going to use my bat.
I wasn't paying attention, but it's okay.
I'm paying attention now.
You're doing great.
Thank you.
See, positive reaffirmation improves the player.
Yeah.
Oh, you're so right.
You should do that to me more often.
Well, like, it only works for certain players.
Oh, so I'm not one of those.
I do better if you have a sub through, actually.
You're so right.
My role model.
It works for certain players If it works for, I don't know
if it works for TSM, who's the number one team?
I don't know.
You're so right.
Oh my god, stop looking at me through the rampart wall, you
freak.
I need five damage.
I'm gonna scan the top.
Yeah, see, they're still there.
Yeah, they are.
There's playing really weird.
Oh, there's a pack.
When he pops his head?
I want to get this care pack in front of us.
What is it?
It's a fucking crazy.
I don't need to shoot any more!
Nice.
I got you.
I kind of want to see how he's trying.
How did you get purple?
It's like he's scanning another package.
I'm going to try to get this one.
Let's see if I can do it.
Oh.
It's going to be really risky actually.
Bro.
Can you guys shoot this building?
Yeah.
We're shooting.
We're looking at them.
Looking at them, but I don't see any of them.
Yeah, they're not looking at us.
I think they're here.
I think they're on this fence right now.
They're trying to get us back to.
Someone just opened this door.
No, they're not.
They're still over there.
Why don't you guys look over here, too, and shoot this team
if you guys can.
Okay, I'll go shoot.
I'm shooting left.
I'll do that.
All right, we need to get underneath these guys, by the way.
It's okay.
I closed this door.
We're good.
Oh, we...
Okay, where do we have to go?
We need to get underneath them right now on the second
floor.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Actually, actually, I joke you, can you scan right right
now?
Uh, which right?
Actually, can you come to me.
Come to me down below.
First floor.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Okay, come to me first floor.
All right, keep moving right side.
Come here.
all right you're gonna scan the next building over to the
green room over here okay can we do it yeah yeah scan we're
good okay we're gonna go that we're gonna take it right now
all right come to the first one the bottom right side we're
gonna keep scanning our way and just keep walking it we're
good just moving i have a craper by the way nice all right
we're gonna wait for your next scan we're gonna move forward
a little bit more all right seven seconds yeah you're good
i'm gonna see if there's any extra loot i heard a ship on
the right side for sure yeah Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's not a
big deal.
I want to see if there's anyone in the driver's car.
You want me to scan this building now?
Yeah, scan to the right right now?
Scan both those buildings we can.
Okay, so there's split holding right now.
There's split holding.
So we could easily get in there if we need to.
I'm ready.
They're taking first floor.
They're about to fight, they're about to fight over here.
Okay, okay, okay, I'm looking, looking, looking, looking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, I blocked our first floor.
I know, I got it.
We're good, we're good.
They're about to find the right side.
They're like smoking now?
Yeah, if they fight this, we go for it, I don't know.
There's another team taking a zip on the high ground here.
Yeah, which is good.
Which is really good.
Dude just walked here.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He just walked outside.
I see him.
Yeah, they're across.
They're across the way.
13 blue.
He's coming across.
Good, guys, this kid.
I can't look right now.
I'm gonna try my third freeze.
Yeah, you're gonna go for it.
You should be fine.
I'm gonna get him in the can.
Where is it?
We're gonna get nice.
We gotta kill guys.
Let's go.
Okay, I can scan this.
I'm gonna scan.
Yeah, I just want to see if they're still fighting.
All right, there's no one in the diner, bro.
I kind of want to get...
Can you guys come to me real quick, actually?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here, come to the bottom floor.
Come on, floor.
We're gonna make a crazy play.
Yeah, come here right now.
Yeah.
Come here.
We're gonna make a crazy play.
It's okay.
It doesn't matter anymore.
Yeah, true.
Are we just playing on the...
Are we playing on the roof of that?
Is that what we're doing?
Stay with me.
Just in case.
Come here.
come here we're gonna take the side side come here what if i
miss what if i miss not you're not you're not just play slow
i didn't miss guys and shoot this to the left we have the
shoes to the left the shield shoot this to the left side
come to me come across from that yeah we're good we're good
this team's not gonna be in for that long they're out next
on just play on me let's see what the sounds going i'm gonna
scan wait i don't know where i'm getting shot from you're
getting shot from out top tempo just come to me come call
this is safe this is safe yeah we're good we're good we're
good we're good there's a team underneath us they don't know
we're underneath we don't They do.
No, they do.
They're looking at me.
They're looking at me right here.
Look, look, see?
Oh, his aim is just, his, his cheats are triggering through
the wall.
Yeah, the cheats are triggering.
Bad him, bad him.
We're streamers.
We know what we're talking about.
Oh, watch out.
Air grenades.
Push low.
Play low.
We're good.
We're going to jump down and just fight for the second floor
here.
Okay.
Should be fine.
We're going to just jump down.
We're gonna ult you this you're gonna ult you the staircase
temple late game.
Okay, you're gonna do wait This one I'm peeing right now in
front of me Okay, I'm not the only one that we have in the
zone the next one We're gonna ult you that late game.
We're gonna play for it.
We're gonna play for it We should be fine Oh, they're
portaling out that team I'm trying to shoot the team on our
left.
Yeah, the team on left shouldn't be a problem just when they
zone in route to 10 I don't know what they're doing.
They're still there.
They're ported out.
They ported out.
They ported out for god now This team needs to fucking get
fucked though We're gonna get hoed by these guys.
Hey, they're fighting on Rikos, are they?
I'm with Rikos.
Yeah, they are, they are, they are, they are.
Yeah, we should go down third party this.
We can't wait, play slow, play slow, play slow, play slow.
Wait a little bit, see if there's any trades, we're gonna
jump down.
All right, jump down, jump down, jump down.
Wait, ult me, ult me.
I know, come to me.
Come here, come here, come here.
Come here, come here.
Come on, come on, come on, come here.
Next floor, next floor, guys.
Next floor.
Take the cube, take the cube.
Come here, come here.
Oh, me, oh, me, dokey.
Yeah, tell me how to come to me.
You have to me.
Oh, he did not.
It's okay.
Come here, don't get me.
Come here, come here, come here, come here.
Tell me if every evac, just get on the height, if you have
an evac.
Oh, I do have an evac.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just come to the front side.
Just come up to the same floor.
They're never thinking.
Just play slow.
We're good.
Wait, wait.
Did they finish?
They finished.
I got a kill.
It's like, come here, come here.
Come here, come here.
Oh, shit.
Come here.
Okay.
We're just putting barrels down here and start shooting
them.
They're gonna start swinging us on the bottom side.
We're good.
They lost their cossack.
They locked their cossack.
Nice.
We're good, Debbie.
I killed their cossack.
We'll play right here, right?
No, no one here.
No way to draw on the side.
They're right here now.
I can scan in two seconds.
We got a kill, we're good.
We got two kills now!
Yeah, we're three kills.
I won, too.
I would say we need to wipe these guys.
They need to walk out first floor before we did jump off.
Wait right here.
In the open.
I know they're not going to.
No, that's my...
Oh, you fucking...
I'm trying to fucking thrifes right now.
I'm trying to get the thrif for you.
Nice.
We're good.
Oh no.
The KB, we're good.
Let's go.
Guys, good shit, dude.
Alright, this team needs to jump out to us.
Last little shoot.
Okay.
Oh, they're leaving it leaving.
They're saying it, we're good.
We're getting us getting more, we're going.
Take space, take space, come with me, come with me.
That's a walk.
Oh, you have your ulti, right?
You have your ulti?
No, no, I don't.
temple Tammu's.
Oh, tell me you do.
Two teams fighting here, yes, I do.
Ta-man, you're gonna hold these kids off, you're gonna hold
this kid off right now.
I'm with Nate, I'm needing.
Yeah, go with our grenades.
One team here?
Yeah, but just play my staircase.
We're good, play near me.
Tempo, jump down, come right onto me because you're gonna
die when you jump off.
I'm safe here.
Well, wait, no, no, I'm not.
Yeah, I'm safe here.
I'm safe here for now.
Yeah, back up with it.
Gotta get some barrels down, tempo, and try to ulti forward
if we need to.
They're right here.
There you go.
I'm going to scan them, needing.
Yeah, yeah.
Tempo, throw your ulti on these kids again.
Throw it.
Oh, they're not there.
Oh, I know.
I know, but you need to throw it out.
We saw on the one side of the right side over here.
Somewhere.
These kids have no angles on the right side.
You need to just pressure them.
You need to throw this ulti right here in this corner.
Oh.
That's fine.
I hit the wall.
Oh my god.
There's no fucking way.
You just hit the wall.
We're fine.
We're good.
There's no shot.
That guy's a rat.
That's the last second.
That is a rat.
That's right.
Keep him barrels forward.
Tempo, keep him barrels forward.
We're good.
There's a rat right here.
We want to rush that.
They're costing us.
Oh, I didn't realize that was your third costing us.
No.
Oh my god.
Tempo, you hat.
Fuck.
We just needed to...
I didn't see the wall.
I didn't see the wall and I hit it by mistake.
Oh my god!
We were just waiting for Tempo to do his thing.
No, okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
That's real life, dude.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
It didn't hit the wall.
It hit Wig's gigantic head.
Wait, you're gonna flavor IGL?
Yeah!
Yeah, Wig, your head was in the way.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Me!
Oh my god.
That was so bad if we had that ulti.
My heart hurts.
Great game, guys.
Great game out of us.
We got third.
We got so many kills.
Yeah, we're good.
We qualify for next round, 100%.
Good job.
Wait, wait.
Good job, Tempo.
Staying alive and take that evac tower.
Good job.
Don't nervous.
You got a good call on the evac.
Wait, how did you get up there, Doki?
It was a Horizon Q.
I just took the Q.
Where the fuck did a Horizon Q come from?
I don't know.
It just showed up.
I was like, yay.
I was like, okay, Doki's with me.
At least we can wrap around and do something.
And I was like, oh, someone came in to kill me.
And I'm like, where did you go?
I can't believe that Q.
Change name.
We got to.
We got to unite.
It's not going to let me.
It's going to do that.
i'm on ea app it's gonna be so long okay guys it's okay
we're in sixth now we're gonna get six after all that we
only wait wait wait wait wait where's seventh eighth and
ninth and tenth points wise where they are we are 14 and
then the next four are 12 8 7 5.
okay we're good we're so good okay but but but what what
what the teams right above us are only at 15 and 19.
see we're But like, how did we only leave up one place?
Yeah, that's crazy.
We can end this in second place, guys.
That's, okay, please don't, okay, Tempo.
After what happened last game?
Wait, what am I?
Watson?
I think I can still play Cossack on this.
You could, yeah.
You might want to be honest.
Fuck it.
Let's see.
We're going to be...
Where do we want to go?
Oh, lightning rod.
Everyone can...
I'm down, actually.
I know, right?
Am I doing the same?
Am I playing Bloodhound still?
Oh, yeah.
I mean, if you want to, are you more comfortable on, are you
more comfortable on Bangalore here?
Because Bangalore is pretty good.
I can do either.
We can do the...
I can do Bang.
Yeah.
I'll just play blood.
We'll see how it goes.
We're experimenting now.
We're going to...
Oh, it's a code.
Oh, code's out.
All right.
Codes out.
Yeah.
Oh no, we know.
We're both in here.
Oh, oh, guys.
Guys, did you guys know?
Okay, we should have.
Should have told you.
We don't...
Hey guys, we code out by the way.
everybody we totally want you in the game with us don't
don't worry we we would not be the same without you on the
glue that keeps everybody together no way the spotlight on
my twitch dashboard is the new level 10 hype train emote
there's no way they're doing that to me right now there's
not wait really are you showing that hype train evil they
got spotlight new hype train emote it's level 10 i ended up
oh my god he reminded me why not yes why not they just
wanted you to be sure that you help contribute to success
not your success but like other people's successes you know
exactly and that's all that matters that's so nice i'm
actually a good guy yeah you're such a good guy see thank
you i appreciate that see he already has everything he ever
wanted so he gives his successes to others wow look at it
yeah yeah so turtle beach i'm cheaper wait what hello i
don't know not nice i came back and all i heard was turtle
beach i'm cheaper that's all you need to know i'm weak i'm
weak what was that what that cost was doing before the first
cost we killed that was trying to cross in the open with
nothing but he actually walked my story that was so sad i
felt bad that was the set i don't i don't i don't that's one
i can't lie i did a little more point for us i had no point
for me it's all that matters oh she you're sponsored by
jillette labs i am sponsored by jillette yeah best to make
you get yeah you know we got you know when we were at twitch
rivals hey guys jillette jillette shavers yeah yeah well you
were for what exactly our balls dude wait a minute what
weren't the jillette shavers for our balls it was yeah yeah
they were actually it was like their own manscaping thing
it's a it's a pubic shaver yeah oh damn that i did not use
that you didn't that's not a good sponsor thing to do you're
not not using your own products oh no no you gotta trim the
jungle down a bit did you hear that wig doesn't even use
your product that was shot i'm getting shamed for not
shaving my balls out that is insane if you believe in the
product to save my balls dude it's implied a facial it's a
facial sponsorship it's implied you don't know that we're
just saying your contract how do you know that how do you
know how do you know i got here everywhere how do you know
that tempo oh he has something in there i'll see you atlay
after the volleyball games me and tempo in the showers yeah
after hours he's definitely looking
homie, you know, give that homie a glance over, you know?
Temple, that's low-key the only L.
If I don't move to Texas, bro, is we can't do our own
volleyball league, bro.
It's like, low-key the biggest L.
Wait, wait, wait.
So you're not?
No.
100%.
100%?
I'm actually probably buying a place in LA, yeah.
You're going to move to LA?
I live in LA?
Aren't you in LA?
Yeah, I'm trying to buy a place here.
That's so expensive.
I put an offer down already, actually, on a place.
Holy shit!
That's so expensive.
How much was it?
everyone in my chat uh tempo is now looking for a new
roommate how much did you put down how much do you have in
your bank account how much how much is your what's your
social security number what's your what is your pet's name
what's the coordinates for it who am i playing what the
coordinate ordinance are so like everybody can like look it
look it up why did you say it like you want to ordinance the
reward ordinance we got that reward ordinance guys oh god
We're still locked in.
Okay.
All right, we're going we're going lightning rod.
If there's anyone there I don't really know what to say if
I'm being completely honest.
We we we deviate to Zeus Yeah, probably actually.
Yeah Probably I think we're good.
Yeah All right, well, let's see what happens.
You know your jump master, right?
No, I had no idea.
Okay.
Sorry guys Uh, there might be a team there actually now
because I jump late in there.
Yeah, it's okay.
I think that might be called it.
Yeah, I think those two are just teams.
There's no way they would contest two teams are fighting at
a new site.
Yeah, we're fine.
We're fine.
Where's the beacon?
Why the fuck are they contesting?
There's like 13 teams.
I don't know why you would.
It's so...
Unless you really don't like a team.
I'm just gonna go here.
There's no beacon at Lightning Rod.
Okay, I'm gonna land here.
I'll land backside.
Just in case that team decides to come this way.
After realizing they're being contested.
I feel like they would realize you're being contested like
very early.
The fact that they're still committed to it is actually
crazy though.
low key I think they saw that too oh god I have the buster
sword on this character I look ridiculous the balk sword I
wrote in chat like went during the whole cost of seeing that
guys don't worry you're gonna watch tempo carry and then
people thought that was like the moment where like the the
whole he got that one kill and they're like this is it this
is where tempo carries little do they know yeah what do you
mean wig was in my way oh my god it's off my fat head bucks
it up and then blames it on i think he really said 7 000
times to throw it it's like it's like it's like my it's like
my timmy incident but where is all right well this box is
straight what a stupid prowler did you send the box off the
mountain yes that is so dumb Why does that exist?
Wait, what do I do here?
This there's a bunch of blue backpacks over here.
Everyone needs like tons.
I need I need I have white.
Yeah, yeah, there's tons.
I need it.
I'm heading over.
Just I'm running carbine.
Carbine Fowler.
Oh, that's not bad.
Terrible.
A verbal barber here if I want to.
Oh, we actually there's a devotion here.
I'm about to take this.
Right.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Getting to that backpack.
It's up top.
You know where it is right here?
Okay, you got it.
Yeah, I am heading over here now.
Oh, I got a havoc.
I got a havoc.
Wait, did someone loot here?
I think Doki did, right?
Wait, what?
No.
Wait, which way?
What?
No.
I did not loot that.
No, no, no.
Oh, Jesus, someone's here.
I did not loot that.
I looted this.
Well, someone looted that, so I'm running away.
Yeah, definitely don't play near that.
Yeah, don't.
i'm coming back guys don't worry we need to figure out where
we're getting a evo but evo and then also people scan a
beacon i already grabbed us one evo oh nice okay i'm gonna
go get that fucking thing yeah you're good i'm gonna get
that there's something there's something yeah yeah that
thing that thing we're so drunk what do you mean i called i
called it correctly oh i got the wrong thingy oh wait what's
your thingy What does that mean?
What does that mean?
You got the wrong upgrade?
Was it the tactical cooldown or the ultimate tactical?
Yeah, it was tactical.
I got the eater.
How did you...
Okay.
It's fine.
All right.
Let's go.
We're gonna take this cannon.
To be honest.
I'm ready.
Oh, wait.
There is a band.
I'm checking it out.
There's someone there.
Don't take.
I kind of want to...
I think we go back to me and go into command and maybe hit
the beacon scan.
But we need to hit a fucking beacon.
Actually, fuck that.
Let's go back towards Zeus.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We go back towards Zeus and go from there.
I feel like we were supposed to take the car.
I should ask Raven what we were supposed to do here.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Oh, we probably should have.
Yeah, 100%.
It's okay.
That's not what it is.
Just walk it.
They just left Zeus.
So we should be fine.
They did?
Yeah, they did.
They just left there now.
So we should be fine on the rotation then.
All right, we'll hit the circle scan and then we'll come
back down and see where we have to go from there.
We can, yeah, that, that, and then boom.
Okay.
I'm going to craft one battery as well, because I have only
one.
So I'm going to craft one up.
I have three bats.
Tempo, go hit that circle scan whenever you can.
Yep.
Oh, you're going to get the Evo, right?
Actually, I'll head over to the Evo.
I get the Evo.
You're good.
Really?
You're the bloodhound.
Should we really let the bloodhound get the Evo?
It's like a scan of the Evo getting rattled on this building
or some shit.
Yeah, that would be pretty funny, though.
That would I mean if you die that way I would laugh if you
did die that way.
I would laugh.
Where are those fuck?
Oh, it's over here Wait, do you not know where the ring
comes?
Nope, this is unbelievable Should we take the redeploy?
Oh Guys wait for me.
I'm coming back.
We'll wait for you.
You're good.
You're good I think we have to redeploy right now.
I have not found a charge rifle yet.
I know what a shame All right, we see that zone checkpoint
for sure checkpoint slap north pad to be honest but taking
this balloon right we're just gonna run down and no no we
should we should we should take the balloon all right yeah
take the balloon and i'll go get the evo cash where you guys
just land wall okay okay yeah land inside wall play slow
just land together in the building and i'll just i'll walk
it afterwards and then if tempo and i die then like you can
survive live for us exactly i got you guys and we all know
how good you are at writing oh wait we don't have a people
we don't have a people yeah let's say we know we do we have
a We don't have it right now, though.
Sadly, they won't.
Wait, rank top one has 60 points?
I did not register for me.
Wait, who has 60 points?
The rank one, number one in our lobby.
They have 60 points.
Let's see, let's stay the fuck away from those guys, guys.
Yeah, what the fuck?
I'm good on that, dude.
Are we going here?
Ah, yeah, we're going to walk in.
We're waiting for her.
You got scanned?
From inside the ball thingy?
Oh, I see him.
Yeah, I see him.
i see them they're across the way they're across the cross
across yeah you're good i'm going right now don't get your
tone i'm gonna get on roof and shoot for you you're vibing
okay yeah i'm okay i'm okay i'm alive i'm alive i'm alive
i'm alive i'm alive i'm alive i'm alive they should want to
fight this guys it's a pretty good fight it's a mad maggie
team which is annoying help me tempo do you get the res you
get the res yeah i'm getting i'm getting i altered i altered
good they're already they're in here yeah they're here
they're here they're here i don't know if i can grab this
okay i'm on first floor first uh stairs stairs stairs I'm
backing to you yeah I'm trying to surround down I don't know
if you can try to run as close as I can to you so you can
come grab my banner later I bet you are trolling you're
actually drawn I got blasted from their roof you can you can
rat in this corner and then you can loop around and come get
our banner easy i'm not rowing for anything no no no the uh
the far north side i'm dead as hark i have one medical yeah
you can get a banner from the north side no way no listen
after what he did do not listen to anything tempo says i
mean i'm dead here regardless i think to be honest oh these
kids are terrible bro what are you what are you playing with
the north at the bench those kids are horrible i mean
they're staring at me that this is gonna be a problem i
think over here wait the team that killed us is going to go
that way so they can shoot each and then you know what I'm
saying if you think I'm getting better in this situation I
just want to let you know there's no way there's no way this
is the wig this is the wig show now this is get the get the
beep beep I mean these could send me that would be pretty
funny it would be pretty funny all they have a fucking ramp
our wall just for you by the way you're all no you don't
okay I was gonna say we're fine we're fine we're good you
know you're a rat too What's the issue?
They don't see you yet.
They don't see you.
Trying to figure out where I can just route to you.
I have to go like far, far right, I think.
Yeah.
Just find a hole.
Find a hole for your goal.
There's a hole for your goal?
Yeah.
That sounds crazy.
What?
It's true.
Get in that hole.
I'm about to just let it go over here to the left and get in
this hole.
I thought you had...
Do you have meds for this?
I have one med kit, yeah.
Okay, that's good.
I'm fine.
I just don't want to just, I want this team to get to see
me.
They'll just kill me in two seconds.
It'll be so fucked though.
Oh my god, scan that.
No.
Oh yo, you can get loot here.
It'll be so funny though.
And I'm gonna shit my pretty ass right here.
Alright, we all know who's fault this is, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, he was actually yeah, he was protecting you.
He was I was protecting I was inside the building when he
died Like who is he protecting at that point?
I was protection from the roof and then I ran inside I was
literally inside by when he was dead.
He's not protecting you.
My dad's saying you stole my apartment on Zillow
Dude, that's one of the funniest things you ever said
co-warded order didn't so I just order in this
Shit top notch we do that we get I'm surprised you want to
live in LA.
It's so fucking expensive Yeah, it is but like I don't know.
I feel like I was talking about I was talking to everybody
in my family I definitely want to live here forever.
I'm trying to be like three years in here and then out like
three more years Just like feel good for business and Then
I'll probably just dip out and probably just buy a house in
like San Diego or like Texas or something like that Yeah,
oh, so like you're just getting for your career.
It's you and me in LA and then when it's finally when it's
finally time to retire yep you can in three years in three
years no i didn't say that no no no i didn't say that i said
to retire in three years you're moving that it's it's your
choice to to leave content creation oh my god please don't
do that for the sake of all our viewers don't do it oh my
god Oh Not a fan not a fan at all We're fine.
Is I kidding.
Was it expensive?
Were you are you getting a mansion or an apartment?
No, I'm buying an apartment.
Oh mansion.
I don't know.
It's LA I don't know what the fuck's out of money.
You think I'm making out But like the law of mansion LA is
like 90 million here.
Yeah, I'll call a content creator and spend all their money
on mansions And then and then well, that's funny because
they do that with renting and they spend like $20,000 a
month renting Like a bunch of fucking idiots.
It's so funny Yeah, like us.
My gosh.
I'm trying to be smart with my money.
I'm trying to make it.
I live for free, so you know.
I live for free.
Oh, well.
Good for you.
Not for long.
Yeah, I was going to say this.
I was going to say this.
Not for long.
I'm going to shake you guys out.
My backup plan just ditched me and left for LA.
Whoa.
Who's that backup plan?
Who was it?
What was it?
Who ditched you like that?
Who would do that to a homie?
all right we were about to live together make food together
sleep together oh yeah especially that last one oh cuddles
with tempo would go crazy cuddles with tempo would go
nuclear i thought that's what the homies do i wish i got
landed on you still in there oh yes i got landed on he heard
us yapping they're in front of me you know they see your big
ass gun poking through the wall yeah yeah they they have
your stream up 10 minutes later this is i mean low key they
would ailed the streams type if they wanted to i've been
here for easily yeah i was gonna say this is where you were
hanging out for 10 minutes it's gonna be an easy top 5 with
the boy though wait don't say that you're gonna jinx it
there's no way you can die right here at top six you can get
second place you can get second we're gonna die right do you
have any needs you can get first i have zero okay you can't
get first You can get second.
I like that out of you.
I'm down for second place.
If you had an age, you could get first.
You think so?
Yeah.
You just arc stick one while they're resing, and then you
just spitfire them to death, and then we win.
Oh, I don't know.
We have no arcs.
I have a havoc.
Oh, that's a havoc.
Do you remember what we said about not listening to Tempo's
cause?
Yeah, that looks like a big-ass gun with a spitfire, like a
handle thingy.
Because it's like it has electricity on it.
The brown wooden handle thingy.
I don't think you should like do it now.
I think you should wait.
they see your gun poking i think i'm right over here i think
i'm in oh no oh oh oh oh what was that what oh oh they
didn't see you didn't see you stick to the wall stick to the
wall stick to it if you don't see them they don't see you
exactly that's oh wait no no no wait wait we we saw them
though okay so if you don't move they don't see you yeah
yeah don't move and like oh god they're coming through
they're coming through right now no they're not they're
where is he got his boys his i hear the water no i know you
yo they were stream sniping oh they definitely are gonna
kill you wait oh run it okay now they shoot each other
you're good no i don't think they're gonna be shooting each
other yeah they shoot each other here no i told you not to
jinx this i just heard that kill like 30 times what the that
was crazy wait that gets a duo She just narrated that kid
like four times.
What was that?
What the fuck?
Oh, I mean, top six is fine.
I think we're on EU servers.
I blame the servers.
We're literally in East Coast.
I have 95 ping.
Yeah, I'm fine too, bro.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
Guys, we need a reset here.
We need...
I mean, what's top six?
How many points is that?
Three?
Three, right?
I think?
Yeah.
All right.
It's not bad.
I mean, 17 is not going to be awful for us.
We're definitely qualified for sure.
Yeah, we're definitely qualified.
There's no way one team's going to fucking kick.
I do like making the end games, guys.
Yeah, you know, I do too.
That seemed really fun.
Yeah.
But what about you, bro?
Do you like doing that?
Yeah, Teppo.
You like that?
Don't worry, guys.
I got it.
Nice.
I blame Doki.
How do you blame me?
No, fair.
No, it's fine.
I'm down.
I'm so down for that.
That's fine.
Yeah, yeah.
It's two against one.
We can't lose.
Yeah, it's two against one.
You lose.
I made it.
Wait, what happened?
Our pact is over now.
He's going to play aggressive.
Oh, what are they looking at?
Why are they playing so aggressive or a duo?
I love that.
Yeah.
I'm going to be honest, bro.
I didn't know right that kid.
I think I could have killed him.
Yeah, but then his duo is going to kill you.
No, he would have made it out.
I would have, I would have got a battle off, to be honest.
That was crazy how bad that lag was.
all good they're gonna get sent on here you know what i
should i should have like not res tempo and just ran to you
honestly yeah i was thinking about i was thinking about
taking that fight but i know that zuse station team would
have been stacked on loot yeah i should have left tempo and
just ran that zuse team that was the zuse station team yeah
they flew down just played that yes from there i don't know
why they didn't rotate it farther oh what a foul colty here
oh my god oh my god And the valve didn't get hit once.
That's crazy that he lived that.
Oh my god.
This team is actually so lucky.
Where was our luck here?
If we did that, fucking, you would have died so fast.
I would have got instantaneously.
Yeah.
I would have died in point one second.
Three teams.
Yeah, three teams.
Even my...
Okay, we're at the point where like tempo dies.
Even my child was like, no, tempo!
Tempo!
Wait, wait, wait, let me open this up.
This guy's...
don't worry you can plug us in i was coming at you go tempo
i'm looking at i'm looking at greek space and he's just like
huh my chat's literally saying tempo just like me for real
see i i give i give the viewers the experience that would
have had they played challenges again okay people were like
temples on the roof again you guys did you guys see what i
did in that game i was not on a roof okay i was on the
second floor wait was that on the roof i ran so fast you
were on the roof and then you dropped down from the roof and
you died oh i think no wait wait was there a forklift on the
roof people said you were on the roof my chat was like tempo
versus brood tempo you need to stop going on the roof well i
can't charge rifle if i'm not on well we gotta find other
ways we gotta figure out another way tempo you can't keep
going on the roof it just means death the roofs are the roof
is a problem for you buddy yeah you're you're bad from roofs
for real now oh yeah damn we never even got chance to see it
bangalore is okay
come on okay we're still in sixth we're good we're 10 10
points ahead of 11 so you know yeah i mean yeah you're
killing it i don't know no no no wait how much for 10 points
10 points ahead of 11 what how much for what he oh he muted
himself oh shit i mean myself what did you just say my bad i
You just said how much for what and then you didn't even you
didn't oh how many points are we away from 10th right now,
do you know?
Oh nine.
Oh, we're good.
We're good.
We're chilling Do we actually need the most unlucky
situation to happen to us to lose codes up Let's go I gotta
pee so bad now.
I gotta pee go pee.
I gotta urinate so bad do it Yo, I think I'm feeding The
fuck man what the fuck man?
Mad him.
It's like, yeah, I switched the fuse.
We're good.
All right, this is it.
Wait, are we...
We're in Storm Point.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, what were you before?
Caustic.
Oh.
He's moving too slow.
Okay.
I've been dragged.
This is it.
Now that you're on fuse, everything's going to change,
right?
Now we're back.
Yeah, yeah.
No more roofs.
No more roofs for me.
I'm a smaller roof.
character no more roofs tempo you stay on the second or
first floor or sometimes maybe the third floor but never on
the roof never on our roof this is it this time we're gonna
get like we're gonna get second place because you're not
gonna be on the roof no we're gonna get first place wait
does first place have like oh first place almost is that
like 80 is at 80 points Jesus.
Bro, we're not going to even be first.
Wait, wait, wait.
We can still get we can still get top.
We can get top three.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ, the distribution is actually crazy.
The distribution between the top top 10.
Wait, where did Whig go?
He has to join us.
He has to pee.
No, he's in the lobby.
He's just not moved yet.
Look, it's Whig time to pee it's his turn the pee we we've
we've always seen yeah wait a minute i get a little chance
to pee here too you guys no i didn't judge i was defending
you oh yeah yeah why are you not joining you're chop chop
yeah i fucking defended you i was like we all had a chance
to pee but did we die next round last time what did we die
next round last time uh what do you mean next round no yeah
no we made it past round two we lost round three didn't we i
don't remember i think we lost round three what for sure we
lost round three last week not round no we lost round two
what do you mean did we really okay okay okay all right so
so we gotta make it pass we gotta make make it pass today
then all right yes we have to we have to yes don't you
remember round two we fucking uh you guys i don't remember i
don't remember anything you guys my brain you guys had
trauma and like fucking uh forgot about that oh brain has no
memory no recollection i mean i think i was just hitting
straight copia then we made around three yeah we have three
we died like twice in a row or like before top 10 and then
totally get top three and then we got like left we got like
fucking dropped out of round two yeah we got fucked up we
are so hard we cannot beat those guys 3v3 guys 110 minute
delay oh one we could barely beat that guy like 1v3 what do
you yeah no i actually think we lose 1v3 to those guys yeah
to who the boys the boys no we win 1v3 tempo every time
remember remember our rat jam plan okay yes we were
surprised and then confusion is super effective and but did
we confuse them we did not into them again this time we'll
do we'll do that we'll use confusion we'll kill one use
confusion kill two and then 3v1 the last guy okay tempo
tempo i think you're like on like some hardcore copium shit
every time there's there's i don't know how you do this but
every time every time anything comes out of your mouth is
some hardcore cope right there you know when you're delulu
yeah yeah the Lulu is the shalulu but last week Temu's like
we're gonna make it to the finals guys we're gonna do it we
just we needed we needed one week of practice that was our
last week now we're in the finals I can't believe you
thought my havoc was a spinfire okay look that gun okay I'm
looking at your stream right now that gun is like a big gun
and you know the little knobby thingy the spitfire has a
knobby thingy the brown wooden knob thingy literally
electricity fucking charging up in his face yo that could be
a spitfire skin that's energy skin fire has a blue skin that
has the thingamajig spitfire doesn't have the electricity
charging out of the giant yo that giant knobby thingy threw
me off okay look at that knobby thingy yeah the spitfire has
a knob And that thing just has a big ass knob.
Why does Pavik have that?
Because it's a skin.
It's a skin, bro.
Yeah.
It's a skin.
Yeah, but you're mad cute, bro.
I love you.
That's why I...
He doesn't do well with cops of his.
I can't.
I can't believe it.
That guy was flustered.
Holy shit.
Uh oh.
He said he's broken.
He's like, he's like, wait, what?
He said, oh my gosh, thank you so much.
Yo, he's like super flustered right now.
Wait, oh my god.
It's a fan He's just like oh no, did you say that?
Did you just compliment me?
Don't forget No Valk, so we need to get those evac towers.
Keep them up.
I thought you're on fuse.
Why are you on caustic again?
Oh, we need to we need to we I I I rigged it so that we get
a map thingy Okay, I believe I did not rig it enough.
We didn't get a map thingy I Do we wanna fight some of the
punks for this car right here?
Oh, we're not making this.
Oh, wait, wait.
You gave me jump.
Okay, don't worry guys.
Don't worry, guys.
No, no, no.
Please, for the love of God, we're gonna go.
Get in me.
We're gonna go to this cannon.
You do not make this jump couldn't do this jump.
You do not make this jump.
Don't worry.
Go do it.
Just do it.
Let's see.
I will give you literally $10 of the next land.
I will buy you food if you can make this jump to a landing
run.
Wait, how far do I have to make it?
All the way to landing run.
What about Thunder watch?
Nope, landing run.
All right.
Let me go get Evan one sec.
Okay.
Let me go get Evan.
He's in a like live coaching.
Wait a minute.
He's like Evan's controlling the mouse right now.
He's muted.
Wait a minute.
This is too good.
I had to buy you food.
This is crazy.
I did not expect this out of you, kid.
I'm going to be honest.
Wait, Evan.
Tim is not talking.
He's not talking.
You guys have to split off.
I got to go look.
Don't go watch while you guys are lighting your eyes.
Okay, Tempa.
I got free food now.
Yeah, you do.
I'll buy you one meal at land.
Bro, okay.
Clearly we know what's Tempo's motivation now.
Okay.
Tempo, Tempo.
If we make it the top five in this game and you stay out of
the roofs, we will buy you two lunches.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, what if...
Wait, there's someone else in the room that makes a lot of
money here.
I don't know.
You're doing.
Yeah, that is crazy.
I'm down though.
Two lunches make top five.
please yeah yeah please what if we make top i and i stay on
them no no no no you have to not be on the roof for this
yeah bro i'm gonna be honest someone go find me uh if
someone finds a digi i got you yeah i got you are you ready
yeah yeah i got you deploy here there's a lottery deploys
this time yeah just take them if we need honestly we don't
have them i'll probably take one let me know you guys have a
backpack i need a backpack there's another uh sorry uh alt
excel here okay 10 million i need a backpack too before i
have no fucking backpack blue oh i have a backpack now my
backpack noink it fell off the map again dude what are the
point of these drops
why me god why me okay you said that the last time devil the
compound and left was looted yeah yeah last time yeah i
don't know i'm scared by a survey beacon right here yeah
just pay attention make sure they don't get sent make sure
they don't jump on us yeah yeah i don't think they will i'm
gonna go loot this and see what happens to me over here one
second yeah it's not like you're on an immobile character no
you saw my movement last game
though but yeah i'm gonna get the car too i think for this
is there any scare any any any beacons we hit is a car still
there yeah it is oh i don't think last game anyone looted
this properly because there's no uh i'm sorry i forgot i
smoked accidentally pills were 100 open when i checked there
last time yeah i don't know what the they're doing that
let's grab that evo cash in the car and yada yada yeah 100
we'll go to zoo station again hit the beacon again Should be
a little easier with the try down here.
I alluded to stuff.
I'm a bit low on the resource department.
There's another blue backpack here, but if you can still
come back and get it.
I might go back and get it.
I'm not sure.
We'll see.
Where are we going, Wig?
We're going to go get, I'm going to get the stride in for
us, and then we're going to go towards Zoo Station to hit
the beacon.
All right.
I'm heading over to you guys.
All right, sounds good.
I'll come pick you up.
We're vibing.
Just trying to find out the loot.
My loot's not really fantastic either.
be honest i'm a peak yeah i'm wanting hemlock and well i'm
gonna see if i can find a 30 30 later i definitely don't
need this one sniper ammo but i want to keep it wait does
someone want uh i already have it all right i'm not i'm not
i'm not bringing a moby i'm gonna take it redeploy i feel
like i think we don't need it yeah i feel like if we die
everyone's dead i agree all right let's take this try down
let's head over i don't know why aren't we still what find
the evocash what do you mean i found one oh no oh wait yeah
we only have one that's it i can get chastified a bin to
open an assault all right don't get out the car yet because
i don't know if they're gonna still be here or not there was
an assault bin right here yeah let's get it we can grab blue
why not yeah i swear you drove why would you jump out on the
bridge tempo he jumped What?
That was so dangerous.
That was scary.
But if my co-op's map, the car shoots you up so you can't
really die anyway.
Oh.
Yeah, but he jumped off in the edge of the...
We were at the edge.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god, there's a...
What?
Golden sniper.
Oh!
Excuse me, I'm not gonna do it, buddy.
Yeah, I'll tell you.
Yeah.
Not golden sniper, but the golden sniper threat.
Nope.
Just go.
Sniper threat!
And then it said sniper threat!
Oh yeah, true.
Sniper threat.
I don't think I heard anyone call it that though.
was there a re up here nope oh no wait i have a re it's
almost like prediction tempo's gonna forget and go to the
roof hey if there are no roofs for me to go on then i can't
go on a roof i'm coming i'm coming we're in the car beep
beep all righty beep beep i feel like we're so gonna get
shot no there's no there's if there's still a year they're
playing the game entirely wrong okay because like we're
playing the game semi-wrong right now and we're pretty early
all right tempo go hit the wait why did it all why should
all of us be here i mean i i just picked up a back up we
just go i thought you guys were gonna go craft a yeah i
thought i'm gonna go hit that i'm gonna hit that vegan not
assault bin yeah yeah say beacon i'm gonna cut the battery
right now uh I'm heading over.
Yeah, you're good.
Do your thing.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I have one hunter, so.
Ooh.
That's pretty fire, actually.
I'm going to use my...
Oh, look at the zone here, too.
That's going to pull to the bra armor shot slash Cito, I
think.
We're going to go into...
We're going to go get that evo in your wall, and then we're
going to go into command and hit the beacon again.
All right.
I'm making another bat.
You're going to do that.
My Uber is just disappearing on me.
Right here.
I'm ready.
let's go all right we're gonna go into commands we're gonna
go in the command saw actually yeah yeah what's that command
hit beacon what the what the was that um wait you're driving
is a little driver uh drunk yeah we have a uh we have a
driver that might not know what he's doing doing i thought
we were gonna i thought we were gonna scan the people beacon
here no no no we should move forward let's go ahead let's go
at the fucking scan inside some syringes from these guys
yeah do your thing you're good we're gonna go the scan down
below the the circle scan then we're gonna go to waterfall
and hit the people scan
all right if i die i die yeah don't worry i believe in you
we're good we're good we're good you're chilling guys so
that's why i'm behind you guys so if you guys die i can just
leave yeah not be dead with us like let's keep up with that
yeah yeah i heard something like a boom I think that's just
the ambience.
I think we're okay, but...
Yeah.
Oh, get the ring scan.
Get the ring scan.
Yes, sir.
Get that shit.
We're good to go.
Let's see what goes on.
And we're gonna go towards...
Let's see.
First.
Ooh, that's a really good knowledge for us to have.
Okay.
We're gonna go get...
We're gonna go out this left side over here.
We're gonna go get the people scan, then we're gonna go.
We're gonna go right to zone.
Right behind you?
Yeah, we're good.
All right.
We're playing this right, guys.
This is the way we should play it in the actual game, too.
I can't believe we're actually doing it.
We're learning from our mistakes.
Yeah, we're slowly but surely learning.
Yeah, it's like if we actually did scripts, we might have
No, actually though.
We could have done something with our lives guys.
I feel like if we actually sort of practiced for this, we
could have, you know, made it pretty far.
Yeah.
Hey, we're past first round guys, it's all that matters.
Yeah, yeah, we're past first round.
We didn't do worse than we did last week, which is right.
Should I grab the skin?
Why?
What thing?
I have a cashier.
Go for it.
Yeah, 100%.
Well, I mean, if we place below top five...
Oh, okay.
I know where to go.
Let's go into zone when you guys are ready.
No one knows right now.
Yeah.
Cut to me.
Yeah, we have three Rita ploys, too, by the way.
That's fine.
Just come to me.
We're going to beat them.
We should at least.
We'll see.
We have three Rita ploys.
Just follow me.
Yeah, yeah.
We're going to go right into the house inside Jurassic.
Just keep our moving.
Keep our moving.
All I'm going to say is that if we place below top five, in
last week i agree i fully agree with with 13 teams instead
of 15.
great job well you better in harder lobbies it just shows
how good we are all right let's move it up i'm gonna walk up
and we're gonna try to get into this building left side okay
all right the building's pretty shit but we could definitely
play it if we need to we're scanning all right we're good
take the building we're good okay there's only certain
angles we could play in here though so he's got to play
smart note to self don't don't go on roof no no this like
somewhere where you can get absolutely annihilated if you're
positioned badly what if i get to take that evo cash you
think i can do it go for it go for it i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna do it go for it go for it you're gonna do it you're
gonna do it i'm gonna do it how much you want to bet oh
you're gonna you're gonna it with free how much you want to
bet i can get it why are we betting money why are we on the
same team guys we're on the same team i don't know i like a
little excitement in it a little gambo yeah oh yo i'm ready
to get rich yeah shoot these guys off
Oh my god, they're red.
Our safe space is the staircase, by the way.
Okay.
Those guys are red.
That team is red, by the way.
That's fine.
What the fuck?
They're so scared of you right now.
Let's go.
Eat this four to ten charge rifle.
You're welcome, by the way.
That was my opening.
Oh, I have to reload.
That sucks.
There's a sniper ammo right here if you need it.
They might be like, oh.
They might be like, yo, that's a charge level and a fucking
lumbar.
That's definitely minus tempo in team.
We're going to fight this much.
That's so far, right?
No, stop moving.
Wait, I would fight them immediately.
For round two, are we all changing our full names?
I'm down if we want to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay.
I got a name.
I got a name already.
What are you going to name yourself?
Don't worry.
It'll be a secret.
We can't say it aloud because what's the point of saying?
Well, no, it's going to be on screen anyway.
They're going to know in 10 minutes.
after the first game you know true they won't know until
after the first game one two three four one more here we're
in such a good spot right now by the way are we okay where
is everyone this team behind us they're gonna be on outside
of jurassic there's not many spots to play in jurassic if i
push for this i'm looking i'm looking for us right now onto
kramer kramer on the front side oh that's not oh you want to
play kramer versus charge rifle kramer no we don't
Oh, you wanna, who will win a charge rifle or a Kramer?
My charge rifle is a Kramer.
Respectfully the tempo, charge rifle would not beat that,
even if she's the best charge rifle player in the world.
What kind of fucking comparison is that?
Yeah, you wanna go toe to toe with me?
It's like, God damn right, I do.
What's fucking?
You guys got a charge rifle.
Oh, wait, why you guys are up?
Why you guys are down here?
I'll make a mistake, maybe.
It's like, play there.
You're gonna get a stake?
to make a mistake he's gonna make a mistake he's gonna do
something wrong potentially what is he doing person or
they're fighting over in power i'm trying to see if i get
picks but i don't think they're fighting fighting anymore
they wiped i'm coming back to you there's a drop here though
we're so healthy what's in the drop i'm uh i don't know i
can't see we don't have a scan for skirmisher uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna put my lumbar down now and try okay okay oh you're
gonna get it okay oh you want to go do it yeah you don't
believe do you believe in me uh yeah yeah yeah okay with
your belief i can do this wait did you okay all right let me
know when it's dropping and then i'll i'll go all in i'm
gonna throw i'm gonna throw my hemlock actually i'll throw
my team just ran into that that's fine yeah they're running
right side they're back there's a full team up here it is
not down yet no i saw you gigantic football okay there's a
team behind us as well guys team behind us on our northeast
right when that right when that fence was should i go for it
now yeah you should yeah you should smoke at them make sure
you smoke it and drop your gun first i did okay nice you did
it i did it It's a bow check.
Can't see that.
Okay, that's pretty ass.
I gotta lie.
I'm looking for you.
We're gonna shoot for you.
We're good.
You're good.
You're vibing.
What's your thing?
Okay, I'm gonna grab it.
All right, now we're gonna listen to me.
Ready?
We're gonna listen to me real quick.
This Northeast team behind us, you guys see where Northeast
is in the map?
Tempo, you need to listen to me.
Okay, Northeast is going to push us.
So we need more barrels on our first floor.
This team is going to fight us.
100%.
They have no choice but to.
All of this if anyone wants it.
I got a kill.
Whoa!
Okay, now Tebow focus on the Northeast side.
Come here.
Get this barrel out of here.
That's Northeast.
Top left.
Here, here.
Look at your compass.
Look at your compass, man.
Hey, Northeast and Southeast.
This is a two-two-two they're going to fight us.
Top these as well.
These are the two squads.
Let's get some barrels down so they play our first floor.
If they play our first floor, we just hold inside stairs and
you cost the gold the first.
You cost the gold the it.
Okay.
Don't hit me in the head.
I threw stuff on first floor.
Nice.
Good job.
We're good.
We're just gonna watch that selfie.
So I'm gonna keep scanning it for us You see that team.
I'm scanning.
No, no, no, no.
Well, I'm well.
I'm all decide.
Yeah, I'll be all the ultimate swords have all the before.
Could I help you?
Oh, no, I can't.
I can't open my door.
Look!
Cha-cha, watch out.
I did, I did, yeah, I did.
Nice.
Goodty, goodulky.
Fight, boy.
Hold on.
Fight scriptures.
You're gonna go.
Yeah, I'm batting.
I'm batting.
I got hit!
All dead.
Full heal!
Full heal, full heal!
I'll scan it a little bit.
Just full heal.
We're good.
I'm full heal.
Nice job, guys.
Oh my God, we did it.
There started on this now.
Another team on the left side.
We're good, we're good.
There's some new way.
We're chilling.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Lute up later.
Don't loot right now.
Just play slow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're good.
32 on the, uh, bang.
I shum.
Yeah, yeah, just play slow.
We're doing great.
Watching the stair door thing.
Yep, yep, we're still in.
Good job.
They're scanning us again.
Yeah, we're good.
I have Digi.
Yeah, yep.
Nice.
Good job.
Altar is really bad.
I don't think that works.
No, it's really bad.
I'm looking at them from here.
I'm still looking with Digi.
I'm here with you too.
I cracked one.
Nice shot, Stokey.
Good shit.
Yeah Okay, I'm showing you those guys, you're good.
I'm gonna look out with my oh, that's mine that's my smoke
Yeah On our first floor, we're good.
Listen.
You can even play first if we need we're vibing There's a
lot of batteries don't hear some old thoughts.
I got a lot of bats Okay tell by how long to your old T's,
you know I'm at 40%.
Okay.
I'm using my charge rifle though.
You're good...
Do you think?
We're bobbing.
Oh my god, there's so much energy.
I have like Altus cells and people need it.
These guys, there's two down.
There's two down over here.
Here, here.
Tempo, Altus cell.
Yeah, , I'd probably take one if you did.
Take it, take it, take it.
We gotta kill these guys when are right when they walk in.
I'm trying to kill these guys.
There's two down over there.
Watched out here.
I mean, I can, I need it.
Yeah, right, you just, I'm a scan.
Oh, it is so far.
Oh, they were so far.
I'm going down to first floor.
That's my bad boys.
I just fast call you a foul.
That's unfortunate.
Do you need this alt accelerator temple because I'm going to
use it if you're not going to need to.
No, you should take it.
Don't keep it.
Don't you have it.
Okay, I'm going to, I'm going to use it.
I'm 43%.
All right.
We're going to, we're going to try to swing this right side.
Okay.
You don't have alt clear.
What do you tell?
Oh, Temple ass and you need it.
It's good, it's good.
We're gonna swing right side.
I think I'm a multi anyway.
We're gonna swing this right side.
Okay, we have to.
I have a choice.
You have multi though, Donky?
Could you ult these guys on the right first?
Oh shit, okay.
We'll see what happens then.
On the left now too.
I can smoke.
Are we smoking?
Yo, you guys want to smoke.
So long, I left.
I mean, now it's good smoke.
We're gonna get underneath them.
Just get underneath them.
We're gonna look backwards, okay?
Go now, go now, go now, go now.
I'm gonna left.
Oh my god.
This solo is gonna turn off to the solo.
Let's shoot the solo, shoot the solo.
We're dead.
We can't do it.
No, there's no way.
There's not enough people alive for us to do it, I think.
GG's.
John.
Hey, we'll take that.
We literally can't do it.
Yeah, we'll take that.
We'll take that.
I didn't know.
Yeah.
I mean, we got so many kills though for four, we're
definitely qualified.
Oh, no.
We definitely good job, guys.
That was good.
We played that really good.
That 3v3, like really well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got so many kills.
That, that 410?
Yeah, Falken.
10 helps.
so much.
Yeah, I bet.
Welcome, that assault.
Everyone's just smoking.
I'm just like, not today, bitches.
Assaulting on me.
Yeah, there was, I don't think.
We had such a poor rotation into the zone.
I mean, that's so difficult for us because there's not
enough teams alive.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah, to help us for the rotation.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You back from behind or something?
Do we have a behind to even up front?
No, I think we died.
No, I don't think we did, yeah.
i think we should just maybe smoke that team off and swung
the sun though i got the kps my bad i just didn't think that
team was gonna that solo was gonna stay there the whole time
be able to shoot us it's crazy i think that solo die the
solo is dead now yeah it's top yeah he is died right after
us literally right after god damn it i did it creep us i
know he was those crazy part two is the top of the rock we
need on top of the rock and i'm like dude you're not Fucking
shit.
That's your suck.
Let me make the content.
Let the streamer live.
That is crazy.
We need the content.
We're here to content farm.
Yeah, they fucking farm that endgame.
Holy shit.
What's fourth place for?
That's what's, um, nine points?
Nine points.
That's pretty good.
Nine points?
Wait a minute.
Yeah, we'll take that.
That's great game for us.
Yeah.
If, if, uh, three, four and five fucked up, then we might be
in third.
Oh shit.
No way.
No, I don't think they I don't think they died.
I think that I appreciate that was probably that was
probably top three right there to be honest I've been taking
gas by three four five Good job, though.
Let's go.
We did it Good shit guys next round Okay, let's ready.
Are you ready to change your names?
Remember to put TSM in the front?
You know, I'll change my name too.
I got you.
Actually, we know we can't change our names because then We
have to change it on battle fly and that's fucked up.
Oh Really?
Yeah.
We can't even like add stuff in front of our names.
No, no, no no there is a way uh wait you have to click your
profile yeah nope where's the thingy no someone someone said
there's a way you can add a thing to your name i want to add
stuff to our names though oh there we go i found it no wait
yep go go to your friends list yeah there's a tag on the
left side a friend's list and there's a tag she wants to do
a tag instead of the actual change name itself i get it yeah
but would they be able to see it yeah they can see it wait
wait how do i do it so friend list yeah and then on the left
side there's a thing called tag i want to look that up after
this i'm watching this okay okay i'm gonna hide my apex oh
good job of not dying by the way oh okay at tsm yeah i will
for sure i'll do tsm as well yeah yeah there you go all i
know
all right i'll be right back real quick guys let me just
greek people dm the code when it's ready all right i mean we
have like a 10 minute intervention yo we're in fourth what's
we improved everyone we improved we went from five to four
yeah we did guys guys even though there's less teams we
technically it's an improvement so i'm talking about top
four guys Top four, we got better!
Oh my god, at this rate, we might have a chance to...
First place has a hundred...
First place has a hundred and two points.
We don't think about the first place team, we don't think.
Clearly, they're like actual Pred players.
We have not been Pred for a very...
Temple, you've never been Pred too, so like...
Hey, I got Masters once, okay?
Yo, oh my god.
Season 17, okay?
Season 17.
You've never been Pred.
was crazy oh my god and it was the season 17 yeah season 17
matches man oh my was that the easiest season to get masters
we don't we don't talk about that oh okay sorry we don't
talk about that part though yeah we just talked about season
17 was masters okay oh man all right wow good guys let's go
man let's go let's go i am way more locked in this week than
last week i'll me too my eyes are open now yeah your eyes
are actually seeing normal fps yeah i'm seeing normal fps
and like i i'm not as tired anymore get a round of applause
dude i'm doing it guys the queen of sleep right here guys i
did it i'm so proud of all of us i'm so so my chat said my
wife's laugh is very distinctive like dokees it's really
easy to locate her Do I like the last puppy?
I need to go find you at a convention.
I would know exactly where Doki is every time.
100%.
I'd be in the middle of the convention to hear that laugh.
I'm like, oh my God, southeast.
Doki.
Five meters.
His head is in the direction.
It's the Doki GPS.
Literally, oh my God, that'd be awful.
What do you mean, awful?
You telling me how to drive somewhere sounds like the closer
you are, the louder the laugh gets.
Oh my god.
You know, you know, you know, there's, uh, you know, there's
things you can, there's like a mod, a mod that you can put
on your Google Maps that you can replace with other people's
voices.
Oh, I love that.
Really?
That's great.
I would love.
Wait.
Just put donkey's voice on the Google Maps.
Bro, I want to release that.
Wait, I want, is that a good?
Wait, send me.
I want to release a donkey bird GPS mod.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, funny.
Oh, my God.
Imagine the content.
You know how the cars beep when you're closer?
Yeah.
When you're like parking and you're closer to a wall, you
just hear Doki yelling, beep, beep.
I can't believe you got two kills, bro.
You're the goat.
Oh my god.
Here's the school bus.
But remember who helped him get those two kills.
We're all spitting though, spitting.
Let him go.
I love the school bus charge.
This motherfucker said, what's northeast?
Yeah, I was like, look at the compass.
Look up.
no no no northeast you gotta you gotta say top right that's
the exact opposite what you say no no northeast is yeah
northeast is top right bro what do you mean that's not top
east that's not my right what are you saying that's not top
east that's not to say northeast you broke my brain just
then with that statement like you actually there's no way
you guys okay i'm looking at I'm looking at that compass
thingy.
You guys actually use that?
Yes.
Of course.
I have to learn to use it for a competitive.
What do you?
Yeah.
Quite frequently I use that actually.
Tempo.
People in competitive use the compass.
All the time.
Yes.
Yeah.
I have trouble using the compass when I'm not playing
competitive.
TSM fucking always uses a...
What do you mean?
I've never met a human.
like this i gotta go i gotta go you know that never eat
never and never eat shredded shredded wheat or never enter
never enter a stinky washroom no that's how you tell like
which way the compass goes around what you go you go n e s
and then w and then and then you go over in a circle and
then you're like yeah yeah yeah i gotta do that every time
someone tells me directions in that sense
person that's not a real human he's a real person
country songs right now to smooth me out a little take the
stress off this is great it could have been the drink dude
what did we tell tempo when we said we'll buy him a another
free meal or you'll buy him oh yeah i didn't go on a roof i
was on a second so he didn't go on the roof but then we got
top five was it top five no me was it top five or was it top
three i don't remember i think it was top five top five
overall i think it was like i have no idea but we're in top
five regardless yeah so but did we die top five did we die
top five yeah yeah i don't remember we died fourth we died
oh we died fourth okay no we died third because there's but
we need okay my bad i'm gonna cut you off but tempo when
we're late game bro let's prioritize your ulti like if you
don't have it you need to pop all the excels like
immediately like you and donky are probably just more
important than me my brain was trying to figure out how to
swap my gun wait was that why you weren't listening to me
when i asked you no way no i was healing i was healing no i
am literally watching this you were like staring at the
boxes how do i uh how do i turn off my stream you were like
don't don't
I asked you like three times, do you need the alt Excel?
And I didn't get zero responses.
Okay.
To be fair, Chrono knows this very well.
When I'm playing Apex, my brain is not all there.
Bro, my chat got support.
Even my chat, it's 10 minutes late.
And they're like, she asked like three times.
Christmas.
No one saw anything, okay?
I'm deleting this.
I'm deleting.
I just open my chat and the first thing I hear is, the first
thing I see is he's still looting for some reason.
That is not believable, bro.
Oh, fuck.
VOD's deleted.
I don't know what anyone's talking about.
Oh my gosh.
Deleting the VOD off that is crazy.
That was the moment you had to delete the VOD.
The code's not out yet, Tim, right?
no no it's not out yet i'm playing literally a game right
now with octaves running around so wait you're playing a
game about us yeah i'm already in the game leave no i'm
gonna get a timer and then my one obsession's shocked where
are you leaving where are you in i'm gonna go on a duos yeah
go do a duos i'm gonna do a tour that aim warm keep that aim
warm i'm gonna get that aim Oh this kid's a fucking
shithead.
Whoa.
Bro, can this fucking movement wannabe just stop?
I'm playing a team deathmatch, bro.
You're playing a deathmatch?
There's a deathmatch?
I also saw it's lockdown and the other one.
Oh, I mean, I got the last one for the hour or so.
Oh yeah, it's gone.
It's like control and lockdown.
There's no way I'm playing control.
Yeah, no shot.
No.
I'm done with that shit.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
You're gonna see me so this the chat.
This is the this is gonna be the only time you see me
actually getting to kill somebody Yeah The only time the
other times I cracked people but my teammates didn't finish
the kills for me
I'm actually low-key snap.
I don't need a PK for the day.
I'm going crazy right now You say that but then it's gonna
be like the part where oh my god the tsm doughkeeper is so
fucking in the public lobby it's so cringe
oh my god look he's snapping right now what is going on who
am i who are who is this man yeah i was not doing this at
all all right chow we made the next round oh my bad i'm
muted wait i want to be part of your chat yeah chow we made
it We made it to the next round, dude.
We did it, chat.
Round two, chat.
Round two.
I'm chat.
He streams to only one.
I'm that one viewer.
Only Dunky.
Yeah.
Shout that one viewer.
Shout out to me, the one viewer.
Go shout out to you.
That's me.
I'm jumping right now.
I'm jumping right now in my game.
I understand if you see my POV, you'd understand.
Yeah, I would have got it.
A minute later.
All right.
Yeah, just wait 10 minutes later and you'll understand why I
said that.
Got my triple take.
We have eight kills.
Wait, how many kills did we have last time?
Definitely not eight.
But we did have like several second places and we haven't
had a second place yet.
How do I even see what we did last time?
And so no guy is the most wannabe movement player in the
world.
What is this guy doing?
What are you fucking doing?
Watching this kid just tap straight everything in these
games.
It hasn't hit a shot yet Look he's trying his best They
should laugh And there's just me on pretty little roller
you're like you don't need that The fuck who shot me?
Oh my goodness I found it found what We had 10 kills last
time.
Oh, so we didn't improve.
No, we moved from the placements, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Overall, placements had to be better this time.
Yeah, yeah, overall was better.
Yeah, had to be.
Nice.
Oh, it says go to round two.
Go to round one?
Go to round two.
I thought it said go to round two.
I was looking at the wrong page.
They're good, they're good.
They got the first place got 102 points.
Yeah, they did.
My god damn.
Yeah, we're definitely not that part of the league.
No, we're not there yet.
We're in the part where we try to sneak by.
Yeah, we're the low key.
We're just low key existing, you know.
We're just there.
We're just trying to get on by with anyone really
recognizing us.
Yeah, we're like, just let us pass through, you know.
I'm going to grab that.
Oh, wait.
You guys aren't even in my game.
Who am I telling this to?
grabbing that evil cash for my random nice she's a good
teammate i'm a good teammate
whoo is the code out i don't know not out yet oh the lobby
we we got seated so it's gonna start soon okay all right
this this
Temple, you need to tell me about the GPS mod.
I'm going to fucking, my next release, I'll release a Dohee
Bird GPS mod.
I got that way.
You have to tell me how to do it.
I actually, I'd buy it.
I'd 100 per cent buy it for you.
I would buy it this far.
I would never use it because it would drive me actually
insane, but I would do it.
You have to use it for like a vlog.
I would try it, I would try it just for you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would literally spend my entire day voice acting that.
Yeah, I mean, that's fire.
That's actually such a good idea.
Yeah, that would be so fun.
And I would release it for free, too.
So no one has to pay for it.
Yeah, I'm that nice.
You're such a good person.
I know.
Oh, my gosh.
Somebody stopped me in my charitable deeds.
Yeah.
She needs to make money, too, guys.
Stop her somebody stop me.
I'm just too nice
No way.
I just no regged you brother.
Yes way.
I believe it No way.
I'm getting no regs out here brother My team is really bad
at this TDM.
Holy shit
I'm carrying TDMs.
You know this problem you're carrying in TDMs.
Yeah, I have no idea what you know, that's happening.
We're shocked
That's crazy.
My stream can finally see me kill people.
I'm so happy.
Here's the most movement nerd of all time and just barely
getting any shots.
That's so funny.
I look, he respect the grind though.
I respect it.
Yeah, you know, maybe he's doing a TikTok right now.
It's not about his kills.
It's about the, you know, like those TikTok montages.
Like those like heavy bass.
Yeah.
I love those.
That's your entire for you page.
a little sausage out of me my chat finally is that the part
we're about we're talking about the
compasses are there oh yeah no i can't i can't be the only
one okay there's no way no you're definitely the other one
no no you should ask them in the chat you might be the only
one big dog i'm gonna be real yeah i got someone that said
never eat soggy waffles there you go i'm not the only one I
know the soggy waffles one.
Yeah, I know that one.
Yeah, but they that means they fucking look at the compass
Pause what do you mean pause what does that?
No, I'm trying to I'm trying to I'm trying to figure out
what to say They're like who are you pausing for?
Shit Who are you pausing for?
I'm getting bullied this Oh, now you're getting...
All right.
Oh, wait.
Code is up.
Oh, my game's always going nice.
All right.
Me too.
How long do it starts up?
Yeah.
I'm going to go join now.
Okay.
I'm going to kill him a little bit because I can't leave or
else I got a timer, right?
Oh, yeah.
You do get...
He does get two lunches because we said top five.
Tempo's going to get two lunches.
Oh, shit.
I'm supposed to figure out, uh, where we're dropping.
I'm not getting shot.
Oh yeah.
I'm almost done with my game too.
Um, yeah,
my game's almost done.
My teammates are really bad bro.
I have 23 kills.
The rest of my team has like eight.
I hear there's no like SBMM in like, uh, was it mixed state.
Yeah.
I can't lie how bad this is.
I've had moments where I was like, how is that a team?
How is my team real?
I have no idea.
Cascades.
no way i lose this game dropping 48 kills this is no way i'd
be very surprised
oh no my teammate are you okay oh god team please i were
losing i have 20 i have 24 out of our 44 kills guys someone
help me please Use your hands.
How is that possible?
Please use your hands, guys, your fingers.
Use anything.
Oh, echo.
Echo location.
Oh, this person type eco.
I was like, where is that POI?
It's a great try, guys.
We had a great game.
Oh my god.
Everyone knew on my team right now, bro, that you guys did
nothing to contribute to this.
I was going to be like, whoa, you positive?
your teammates hell no not in this situation that's crazy
wait i'm not dead yet they need one more kill oh my god we
need two more come on no i can't be the last kill i was oh
my god he's got 20 something kills and we lost the game guys
i'm coming i'm coming my team is like my teammates like bot
lobby i think i'm in a bot lobby too Sometimes they make the
fucking bots just fight for XP and then they don't do shit.
They just shoot people who shoot them.
Yo, we're just, we're waiting for you guys now.
Alright, where are we going?
Is it just me?
Get in the game, get in the game.
Don't get in the last one.
Oh shit, okay.
Sorry.
I gotta go.
GG's.
Okay, wait, where are we landing, Tubbo?
Okay, I'm going in.
I'm coming in.
Okay, cool.
Okay, so right now, no one typed...
I'm here.
Zeus, Elrod, Command or Stormcatcher.
No, you don't see the TSM in front of me.
You lied.
Wait, do you not see it in front of me?
They see it in the game.
No, I think it's not.
I also did not, I also lied and I did not do it.
I forgot.
You didn't do it?
No, I forgot.
Totally forgot about it.
I was too busy on that team.
They're going to wait for you.
No, the fuck they're not.
Please, wait.
Wait, need to do, need to leave love.
No, no, no, stop.
No.
I am not risking this.
I'm not risking this.
JK.
He's a cow.
he's a coward what the man oh wait wait we actually have
good teams in here oh shit yeah we got we got uh we got pain
we got sq we got we got double o negative i have no idea who
any of these names are you're not gonna know anybody ever
and i think i think that's it right so just those three yeah
three different teams are good say this round two is easier
than last week's round we're taking we're taking three
different pois though okay we got zeus command and lightning
rod i i tell all three yo wait you type lightning rod just
so people know all right i'll type yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
wait how about all three of us type lightning rod and
they'll think it's all three different teams because they
don't pay attention okay lightning rod i type i say
lightning rod too so they'll think like three different
teams are going to lightning right yeah you're showing Watch
this, watch this.
But.
See?
Now, now, now they have to be so confused.
No, you should have been like contesting team 11.
Then it'll be even more confusing.
Okay, it'll be like.
You know, there's like there's like three teams landing
Northpad.
I'll be like contesting team one.
Contesting team one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
People will be so confused.
People will be so fucking confused.
Yeah.
it's gonna be great so we're on storm point first okay cool
w we'll take it we'll take my team said or my you would be
the second person to die in a horror movie with that
direction what you i think i think i think i just caught up
you would yeah you would be the second you were in a horror
movie who's the first i don't know he's dead you he's dead
why would it be me i know my cardinal directions no no tampo
is a hundred percent first dead in harmony yeah i'd take the
second place that's that's messed up i would survive i would
survive in a zombie thingy no you won't no you would not i
would definitely survive in how i would be the zombie oh
because i think i either i think like 10 was gonna die first
then wig then me because i the moment wig gets in trouble
i'm gonna run away oh my god you just leave me fuck this
team i'm out 100 it's all about survival wait someone said
grief team are we are we fighting a team off one why no no i
think they just want us to land on team four they want us to
land on team four or something just type sq i'm never gonna
watch that code net i've got code net Oh wait, code net?
Oh, wig got code net.
Wait, change your name.
Tag.
Do your tag.
I don't know how to do that.
I don't remember what it was.
It's go to your friends list and then there's a tag.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
I knew it.
Oh my God.
Wait, it happened for a reason.
It all happens for a reason.
It happened for a reason.
Wait, are you back?
Are you back?
I'm back in.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Look at that.
I knew it.
I didn't remove from the custom match.
They just took me out of the custom match.
They just, what?
You bugged out.
We kicked you out.
They saw your TSM.
Do we need to somehow get a DC restart in case we DC?
What group are we?
I don't know.
We are.
Everybody's here.
Okay.
Group 15.
All right.
No, I'm just getting ready just in case.
Oh my God.
We made it to round two, guys.
All right.
We're back to it.
we started last time guys can you make a post this round we
got 12 last we celebrate we got 12 last game last week we're
going for we're going for seven yeah look i just be happy
with top 10.
you know i'm gonna be honest bro i'm happy with ninth place
i'm happy with tenth i'm gonna be real like just please just
yeah that's all we want let's get me a school bus let's go
we got this shit easy i believe in us guys fully i believe
chad thank you all for being here supporting everybody's
chat love you guys thank you everybody you guys smaller ping
what what did you just said if you click ready you get you
get smaller ping okay now that's some fucking cope shit
right there there's no way that's true there's no fucking
way
we can do this I believe there's no way there's no way we
can't get past like top 10 this time no this won't be good I
think this lobby is easier for sure yeah okay but what
happens if we and we have Zeus I mean we want to be honest
yeah how did we feel about that game okay I think yeah we
had we had a million me back hours yeah okay yeah let's make
sure we get our evacs that's like the biggest thing yeah so
do we do bang then there yeah yeah okay bang I'll play one
okay okay where does where does the beacon spawn in
lightning rod um I mean we haven't had a single beacon yet
in lightning rod but this is it round two if it if a if
beacon if beacon spawns in lightning rod so one of you guys
has to swap and go thunder watch because I gotta go to
wherever the beacon is right yeah yeah i can do that i'll
take over your place if we get the beacon okay all right
let's do this all right i believe oh there we go i see it it
says tsm yeah yeah exclusive right now why we we wanted to
wait until now to announce it but we got signed by tsm yep
three new content creators signed to tsm guys yeah you know
how like uh temple was getting kicked out of his house uh
wait wait because yeah it's because he's getting signed so
they're getting him as a content cloud you're so smart
you're still right tsm dokey bird let's go tsm dokey sounds
fired i better see that in the competitive face yeah yeah we
better see this on reddit yeah yeah someone better put this
on god i better see that wait do we not have a beacon again
oh we don't okay no we don't we don't but we have this is
gonna sound crazy can we pass the jump master tempo oh
actually though he was really evan get back here all right
wait i'm gonna try to go and get the car on the right side
okay so don't keep the front of lightning rod and i'll just
i'll go from here and go the back but just leave all you
need in my mind if someone just did not call yeah if
someone's going mining rod we 100 just land thunder watch we
try to rotate out but we have a good jump here should be
pretty clean i don't think anyone's gonna be too crazy about
it we should be fine yeah as of right now it looks like we
are uncontested for sure really as of right now yes it does
oh there's like no one team one team one team one team one
team might understand lightning rod i think so yes yes yes
where do i land yeah land on the watch land on the watch
side land on the watch side go thunder go thunder don't get
back up back up i'm gonna loot this building and i'll go you
guys go thunder okay did they take take it yeah they got it
okay that's fine i was gonna run you guys immediately i'm a
carp i got some good loot yep i got some good loot i stole
some of their shit and we're gonna dip out charge rifle nice
okay they're gonna maybe try to fight us here too but let's
just try to keep on moving did anyone go storm i didn't idea
okay my audio is not on okay that's not good now also just
be hyper aware these kids get 100 push us please i have a pk
here okay i'm good i'm lumboh havoc i'm okay i'm okay too
i'm trying to see if anyone went storm they did okay there's
a team storm these kids are low-key us here but it's okay
that's what it is okay i have good guns i have ball and
carbide okay what we're gonna do i think then we're gonna
run to the left okay we're gonna go left side over here all
right go left side over here when you go east side southeast
side and we're gonna go get this car they shouldn't they
shouldn't shoot us i don't think yeah hypothetically right
yeah for sure i'm gonna stick to the right side if they're
here then we just kill them honestly honestly or or do we
rat inside the compound and wait for one of their idiots um
and then use it and then use the confusion tactic no she's
gonna go actually
cooking let's stop cooking let's get in this car and we're
gonna go down to spiders okay okay i wrote to now just get
to me immediately i'm here can you honk can other people
hear the honk yes of course yeah okay we're gonna we're
gonna leave this compound okay okay dude up let's just stick
together though because i don't know what this team's gonna
do for me honest i'm gonna i'm gonna grab the evo yeah go
for it
just keep uh keep your head on a swivel just in case all
right not last what not last oh my god you scared me and not
last let's go we'll die first we're good yeah we're good oh
god you lose these okay did y'all loot this in here or now i
just i looted the second floor okay nice i'm gonna go across
the street and loot across right are we going down this yeah
yeah we're gonna take this we're gonna take the trident
though we're gonna navigate with this car for sure here oh
well i'm already gone oh that's fine let's be sure i'm gonna
try it i thought you're gonna loot across uh i'm gonna be
honest we want to go for i'll come with you tell me i'll go
too far away from us okay and uh that's there will be teams
probably rotating out and i want you to get shot at or i'm
gonna stay in the nuts we're not yeah yeah wait for your car
yeah yeah i'll wait for wig i'm hanging out with wig we're
vibing we're vibing we're looking so good so juicy my looks
not honestly terrible for what the we got yeah i honestly i
feel like i have good loot we just need another evo or like
assault we're gonna go find we're gonna go find another evo
right now hey time we come to us tempo come in uber's here
are we gonna do spiders or you can grab the evo yeah we're
gonna go you get the evo on the left side just stay in until
i tell you guys to jump out just in case let's go eat this
evo though all right someone get in there okay Nice i got us
Oh, I picked the wrong one.
Oh It's okay.
I might pick the wrong one also That's a lot of it's a lot
of all the excel All right I got healthy so and a medicate.
We're good.
Good.
They include you guys in here.
Yeah, I'm gonna grab some so guys I might also pick the
wrong one.
That's okay All right, we're gonna go.
We're gonna go now to launch us good.
We're gonna go to devastated hit the beacon okay all right
yeah we're gonna get the other evil on this back left side
oh okay yeah why is there an evil here i'm gonna be honest
bro i have no idea i don't think i've ever seen this one
yeah that's so fucking far i'll grab it yeah i get it get it
yeah i'm the evil girl yeah you are that's me let's go all
right i'm checking the map real quick oh oh whoa we're gonna
go back aboard mission it's fine yeah it's all right
honestly let's get in here and get out of here we're gonna
go in this one okay all right all right let's just play from
here right now i have no idea where the zones going because
we have no beacon it which sucks but let's just navigate our
space let me let me know if you find a uh or a sniper scope
yeah we're gonna take the height of this so we're not gonna
play inside here we're gonna take the height okay oh just
because i don't know i just don't know how many people are
here what how many where the zones going i want anyone to
come and just feed on us so it doesn't end You're good,
you're good.
I'm gonna go top.
Hopefully no one's up here and I die.
We're good.
There's no way.
You're so healthy.
I'm so healthy.
I also got...
I can look over you guys now too.
I'm heading up.
Whoa.
There's a scope here.
There's literally a scope in front of you.
Yeah, I have a...
Yeah.
I'll grab that.
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna set up here.
Seems they're rotating in this way.
I think it's going pylon, to be honest, but I'm not sure.
So we'll just play from here.
We'll open their backs just in case.
Yeah, you can do that.
All right, you guys play up here.
I'm going to go get these two bins up here.
Just case it's nice.
Sounds cool.
Where were you shooting?
I want to.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was a team.
It was a team in Taiwan, yeah.
Looking behind us.
Yeah, they're fighting someone else.
That's good.
Just get shots down, go for it.
We're going to put people up here.
Team here.
Okay, I'm going to leave after this.
You shoot at, too.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going to leave right now.
I'm going to go get these bins.
He's behind that box.
Yeah, he's not peeing though.
Like I said, though, there's a lot of people that are coming
over here.
I think it might actually end your us.
Should we be here then?
There's another team fighting here.
Yeah, we should definitely play hide if it's going to end
here for sure.
We can evac hide if we need as well.
It's a really good spot.
I'm just trying to find a scrap.
There's another team fighting here, Tempo.
You want to shoot?
I'm going to look behind us still.
Yeah, there's a team now walking into Launchpad backside.
I think we're in a really good spot, guys.
All right.
This is our new home now.
I could 100% 1 million, 1,000% be wrong, but let's just
check it out.
We vibe out for now.
what happened to that that was walking behind us i don't see
them anymore whoa oh gee oh i see it hello wait land behind
us now too just i need a heal i'm gonna go be next i'm gonna
be honest i'm not gonna peek until the next zone closes i
think i need to hear yeah yeah i was right now i stood on
top of it almost glided in wait we're actually in such a
good spot look at our zone call oh my god look at this look
at that r-i-g-o right there yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm way more
locked in this week i'm telling you that's our guy that's me
that's me that's him cpots affirmation works don't worry i'm
not gonna peek too much because i don't really have that
much good meds i have two bats nine so i have two bats uh
seven i'm two seven okay tempo can you get like one or two
barrels out here if a team ubs us just hit the barrels there
you go yeah because i don't think we want to peak too much
right now but i want to show a little bit of presence if a
team just ubs on us suck all right so here's the here's the
here's the game plan guys if a team if a team ubs just goes
yes yeah yeah yeah grenade it and i have an old excel here
anyone needs it later okay though all right okay we need six
more teams to die yeah we have one more one more point teams
are stream sniping.
You want us to make it to the next round so you get content
and clout.
Also, also, we're easier to kill.
So it's like better to have us longer.
Better to have us longer in the lobby so you can get higher
placement just so you guys know.
You're so smart.
So if you're stream sniping us at the moment, remember this.
Yeah, remember everything.
Remember me.
Remember us.
You'll become famous for being in our lobbies.
This is going to be your big break.
You're a big break.
Drake is crazy.
Oh my god.
This is your chance, guys.
This is your chance.
Let us in.
Just let us into round three.
You're going to be famous.
Okay, I'm going to shoot it with you.
I'm going to shoot it with you.
If we get any hits, I'll be so funny.
I hit one.
I can't even see where you're hitting it.
Good enough.
They're rotating left.
So I think I might pull a little more towards devastated,
but we're in a really good spot with an evac tower here.
it yeah they went yeah they went here that's fine they're
gonna hit the people scan i think that's what they want and
the ring console i see them up here yeah yeah they're right
here now oh they're finding someone 46 seconds we'll find
out good that's another team gone you need that oh my god
someone else has a someone else is also a caustic with a
charge rifle
person farm evil now actually i have to try i think it's my
least favorite part about it i was so useful back then yeah
because you were the evil farmer yeah i was the one guy with
the rifle yeah yeah give me your shoes guys what was it
what's it wait for i don't know uh charge or ammo what take
some bro i think i actually understood what you were saying
that's insane Yeah, I was like, what did he just say?
I agree exactly.
The fact that I understood that was unbelievable.
It's probably because I speak mumbo jumbo too.
I was going to pull towards Devastate.
We're in a really good spot though.
We just play up here.
We evac.
And then we evac.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're valid.
We have how many evacs do we have?
Either one.
You guys?
I have one.
We have two.
We have two evacs.
Okay, we're going to pop.
We're probably going to have to do a double evac.
So our sources get shot out.
We just jumped.
Team just went on to the bridge.
Okay, nice.
We're doing great right now.
I believe in you.
yeah we're valid we're all we're safe we're so safe it would
be funny we like temple got like three three bad shot from
that if you just not if you pooped me and then i got just
triple small yeah like keep flying to my ubus my ubus okay
they're above us they're above us you're gonna come here i'm
a need ready oh shit yeah yeah i'm batting i have a I think
they landed on the right.
I don't think they moved us.
Okay, okay.
It sounded very scary though.
Yeah, I was like, I looked up and I got shot.
Yeah, it sounded very creepy.
Why did I get shot?
What the f- Shit on?
What the fuck?
That was my bet.
Where did they land?
I'm not sure.
I think it landed underneath the reds.
I got a scan right now.
Yeah, scan.
Yeah, they went red room.
Red room.
What's red room?
It's like between the toes.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Little red rooms.
I'm sad.
I can't be helpful because I only have a carbine.
That's okay.
I'm not really doing much either.
I don't have I don't have enough heals for us to do any shit
like that anyway We're doing we're doing pretty good for not
we're doing pretty good for not uh for having the like a
contested drop And also just having like farm evos early
with a trident.
Yeah, it's pretty hard.
There are two solos that just die You got something left
side Three more teams three more teams.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
Tembo, can you do me a favor?
Can you move this barrel up like right here?
Move it up just a little bit.
Yeah, the middle one.
Yes, I could play if someone ubs us or comes up here I could
just play it right?
I goch.
What is ubs?
out of bounds like a land out of bounds and land on you oh
wait they're fighting bottom left wait shoot this shoot this
shoot this shoot this shoot this shoot this shoot this okay
i'm gonna get a shot kb oh motherfucker baited in i got 10
damage nice good 10 damage so huge so huge trust
contributing nice and then you just took 400 yeah we're good
we're good yeah yeah yeah right here we're good we're good
we're good dude why are you shooting us you fucking bombs
sorry guys yeah say it say your feelings oh we're good we're
good you're gonna explode if you you don't yeah you don't
don't keep trying to give me have another clip on twitter
bro any publicity is good publicity oh my zone okay it's
really bad oh that's bad for us yeah it's a really bad zone
okay we're gonna evac late okay that's all we're gonna do
look at this double evac late it's fine that's fine is it a
building no we're gonna evac from the top i don't know where
we're landing i have no idea yeah we have to check yeah yeah
we No, what we're probably going to do is land for the
staircase in the back over here.
If we can make it that way.
We'll see if we can get the EVAC off.
We're going to go very late though.
We want other teams to die at first before we start rotating
in on this.
And other teams get focused because we just go early, our
EVACs can get absolutely rocked.
Yeah, I feel like everyone's going to shoot our EVACs at
that point.
100%.
We need this team on the left to start moving up and stuff
like that before we get rocked.
How much sniper ammo do you have, Tempo?
You've been charged rifling forever.
12 more.
Oh, okay, that's not a lot.
Towards the end of like 20 seconds until the zone closes in.
Make sure you guys have full HP, please.
Okay, okay.
I'll try.
All right, a couple of you guys started coming out.
All right, so you see my plane over here, guys?
Over on devastated.
This thing right here.
We're gonna land for those staircases probably, okay?
Okay, okay.
Backside of it.
All the way in the back.
Spamping this one.
I don't know, I will.
We're gonna go late again.
We're gonna go late.
Oh.
We need these kids on the left to fuck off, bro.
Like, we can leave.
What are they looking at?
I don't know why they're staring at us.
Why are they staring at us?
Are we like, did they know it's us?
I don't know.
Maybe, honestly.
Who the fuck knows at this point?
Like, is it 10 minutes past and they know we're here?
I have fallen.
What the fuck is wrong?
Are you gonna smoke this hide, I think, Doki?
You're gonna smoke these guys.
No?
No, wait like five more seconds.
We're gonna go.
Okay, let's call for it.
I will.
I'll let you know.
Oh, they smoked us.
Nice.
Okay.
All right, ready?
We're gonna go.
Come on, go, go, go, go.
Here's another one.
I can't put the other one.
That's fine.
I'm gonna hold these two and land.
We're good.
Okay, just follow my pattern.
Just follow me, stay up height stay on height stay on height
as high as possible Oh, there's a team right above us by the
way We're found we're fine.
We're fine.
Just come here.
Yeah, we're gonna land right here on silo Okay, we'll land
right here We're good What are you gonna help?
Offed on someone's head wait what who the fuck is this guy?
Wait, Tommy Don't get shot in the corner to the corner to
the corner.
I couldn't the other team shot I got two I killed two
friends.
I killed two friends What the fuck?
Where do those guys have?
You guys see those guys?
No, I saw you got punched.
I was like, who's that?
Wait, what just happened?
Who the fuck was that?
It's okay.
I killed a ranked 56th friend.
No, good job.
You guys four points.
But what the fuck was that?
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
I didn't see anyone there at all.
Was that the team that even acted with us?
I don't know.
I just got punched.
I didn't hear a thing, bro.
I didn't hear that.
Oh, JK, I didn't kill a Pred.
It was some other fucking...
Some fucking 4K shitter.
I don't know who they are.
Hello?
4K shitter.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I like lost that pod back.
Me too.
You said someone landed storm, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
So right now we've got high line, down beast, and command
that we might be able to land at.
Man's not bad because we can evac out of there if we need
to.
Okay, do we want to just aim for command then for this one?
Yeah, I'm down.
I still don't know where they came from.
I'm still lost.
I was so confused when you got punched.
And I was like, that's not tempo.
I was like, that's a rampart.
That makes no sense.
I'm so confused as to what the fuck just happened to me.
Me too.
That was so weird.
Because they definitely were not there when we landed.
They were 100%.
Yeah, there was nobody there.
They landed the moment we, like, landed, I think.
That's so shit, too, because that's so fucking winnable.
We might have got sent on by this team inside, but we got
absolutely sent on because of that team landing on us.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
There was no way I could live as a rat, too.
No, no, no, you got even such a good job against two points.
You got us four points when we would have gotten one.
Yeah, let's go.
I contributed.
No, you did more than contribute.
You carried good shit.
That's just that's just insane.
I cannot believe that just happened to me.
I know.
I was like, what the fuck?
I was like, where did they come from?
Getting punched is like the least expected way to die in
that situation.
Yes.
They literally teleported into us.
I think they were just as surprised.
He's like, I think the two.
Yeah, they were like, because they started punching.
They didn't even get their guns out.
How did you get two kills?
Wait, if they were punching, yeah, then they must have
landed right when we landed.
Yeah.
I do.
Because like, when Wig was getting shot at, I got one down
and then the other guy, I don't know why he didn't, I mean,
he shot at me, but he lost the 1v1.
Yeah.
I know, he got it.
It's still can't embarrass him that losing that too.
I can't believe he lost the one.
They're kind of goaded.
Oh my god.
Wow, they got four.
The team I'm watching right now is going to win.
They're just farming everyone.
Yeah, GG's.
That's the farmers.
Oh my god.
All right, I need to fucking pee so bad.
I'm going to be back.
All right.
GG's.
Got 10.
That's better than...
No, dude, good kills.
Seriously, really good kills.
Those four points are going to be huge for us.
Yeah.
two points we're gonna we get like four or five points every
game then we call yeah we're good i'm gonna be all right
we're gonna do this we're i don't even know where you landed
we just need a i landed on top of the the the silo thing
yeah and then you got shot down i landed on top of it then i
got shot as i was jumping down and then yeah and then and
then i died yeah and then i died and then you disappear yeah
holy shit that was fucking crazy oh we are in ninth we're
nine let's go if you if you didn't get us those two kills
and the placement we would be tied for 13th that's good we
got ninth place we're gaming our gamers gamers gaming 11
kills okay we're doing so well i knew it i knew we're on
track we're on track
we're on track we're on track to qualify for round three
i've always believed in us look tempo tempo if we make it to
round three i i will give you enough money for a third lunch
oh my god i'm making lunch and we're calling we made we made
it out of round one you make when we make it to out of round
two you'll get You'll get, like, lunches for all of land.
Right, deal.
How many land days are there?
Three?
It's seven days.
Seven days?
Okay, yeah.
Third.
I'll give you a third.
It's seven days long.
I'll give you a third lunch.
Day three lunch.
Wake will be in charge of day one and day two.
I'll be in charge of day three.
If we make it to- All right, I'm back, guys.
I urinated.
Yeah.
Wait, we made a deal.
We're in ninth.
If we make it pass round two, I'll buy day three of land
lunch for a temporary.
of are you going to land no i'm just gonna send him money oh
it's a way cooler deal if you were actually there yeah yeah
exactly if we make it to the finals no there's no if we make
it to finals you go to land yeah we go to that if we make it
to finals oh man okay deal we'll do it then win this one
wait the code's not up though no it's not up yeah we're just
waiting oh it is oh never mind it just got out i just put
the code in it didn't go oh no i went there there i'm here
bro what team landed on us at devastated no no no way no way
who landed siphon who landed no way so siphon l ron ban from
any events i'm insane you're the goat for that bro i'll call
a water jug one second
no actually speaking of which you know that you know how
there was a oh wait wait till wigg gets back too so i don't
oh it was a dg dg was the one that landed there wait really
yeah all right well they just outed themselves so they're
not playing in any tournaments anymore
abuse they're not even gonna tempo they're not even gonna
make it to any abuse no i i mean there's there's there's
some uh open events you know and then it'll just be like oh
it looks like your application just disappeared oh i
accidentally deleted this row of applications damn power
abuse live on stream oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so so okay so i
was saying uh nice if they if they you know that you know
the uh the 25k sword tournament yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
running through the qual applications for that so oh goodbye
dg looks like you're not making sure damn damn
quit snitching
that was me thought i had my gun out is crazy yeah that's
the guy i punched you that's the guy that punched you yeah
motherfucker dude don't fuck that guy ban from watch parties
yeah not allowed to watch the watch parties anymore wig is
not even gonna let you watch the party
Yeah, I'll copyright strike you imagine.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
If you watch your stuff, we're going to copy it.
We're going to.
I'm talking right away.
Copyright strike.
No, it's like I showed up on your stream.
You saw me on your stream.
Copyright strike.
That's my identity.
That's my video, yeah.
I break the number one rule of content.
I should do not copyright strike unfairly.
I'm just talking to everybody.
Everyone.
Throwing it left and right.
you get one this guy gets one yeah i show up you saw me in
that one game i'm gonna strike you now say goodbye to your
channel you know okay you know the most evil thing you can
do if they have song requests on and you may play a song now
we get them
imagine you play your own you make an original song and then
you play that original song on their do have an original
nice week strong oh my god oh my god use it are you playing
that at land oh no play at land and then copyright a viewer
made it it's really good copyright strike everyone that's
watching yeah we had the free watch party on the stream feed
stream and like uh didn't the fine brothers try to copyright
literally react yeah yeah they did make they train hard
react they're like you can't do react content that's gonna
be you you're you bring your original song you play it on
your b stream channel and anybody that watch parties your
stream they have to give you the revenue they make from that
stream they need to give half to you wow i'm rich because
because you had your song played it's just like youtube when
they strike you you have to give half of your you give
content wait wait someone said their command oh i'm command
someone else said their command the run the ransom perk oh i
know we could just go towards thunder watch we wanted okay
depending on where the ship goes yeah we can we can check we
can check to see if pylon is open too because that
technically i'm gonna be honest bro i definitely think
pylon's taken but we'll see i think well barometer is
technically still open too because why three one two six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
my audio back up uh barometer and pylon should technically
be open but we'll see we'll see see how it goes
right we can't let doki's four points go to waste we got we
got these next three games i worked so hard for those fights
we got this no really good two kv i just watched it back
that makes no sense how they did not kill you okay we'll see
if anyone goes into command there's no lightning round right
now okay yeah yeah i think i think when i said i was gonna
ban them from all the tournaments they got scared and left
nice that's low-key horrible but i love it power this is the
reason why tempo is in my game abusive power you guys you
guys land here uh tempo go thunder and then i'll go get the
car i'll get the car over there this is the abusive power
man i'm gonna make sure that you're not getting landed on
though you're good you're good okay i'm letting everyone
here and now i'm gonna go up all right yeah we're good i'm
actually surprised they left oh my god i think they actually
you're serious that's done someone's gonna make a red post
about you i think what actually happened is i think they had
a worse game than us to be honest oh which is pretty tough
well we stole their car too so they're not really getting
anything out of it yeah they're just like they're just gonna
keep stealing our car we just might as well dip yeah i'm
literally taking the most important aspect of their gameplay
and just i gotta redeploy
so much so almost like i can't believe she got them a 4k
Yeah.
4k shitter is crazy awesome.
I love that out of you to be honest.
You can't if you have your 4k badge and you lose to my badge
right here with the fucking double bronze.
What are you doing?
I don't even have a 4k badge on this account with my
Bangalore.
That is so ridiculous.
All right, wait, is there a beacon for us to do?
No, there's not.
sucks.
We haven't had a single beacon here.
Yeah we have really bad luck when it comes to the really
important rounds to not get the really important stuff.
To be honest.
It's pretty sad.
I'm not going to that.
There's a really good at that.
Just not getting the things we need.
The evac here.
I already have an evac.
I'm good.
There's no evo cash for me to take either.
Like this is fucking torch.
Yeah.
I'm going to blow and shoot happens.
If I die, I'll scream.
Okay.
All right.
Don't worry.
There's a are you gonna shoot that flyer cuz I am for you
Zeus just scanned us keep that in mind.
They're gonna tell we're really separate then.
That's not good There's no way they're gonna rush us, right?
Well, they're gonna go for they're gonna go for that What
they're gonna go for this thing evo cash?
They are.
Yeah, I'm sure.
I'm gonna come back up to you guys right now anyway We
should wait for storm catcher to leave then go back to storm
and get the get the beacons
i haven't found the syringe we should also get that eva when
they're when they're gone for sure i'm gonna grab i'm gonna
kill this dragon okay just for like a little bit of just a
little bit of flyer stuff oh nice at that all righty uh does
someone want that 3x yeah oh come here come here come here
come me come me come me jump off come shooting from behind
us oh they took that zeus zip in the back oh no no i can't
take the pad okay just get to my car literally keep on can
you guys get to me yeah yeah i got it i don't think wick i
don't think tempos i don't know i guess okay okay okay okay
okay do not finish do not finish get in get in get in get in
get in where the fuck they were right but how did they get
there i didn't even see that they took that zip in the very
far back oh uh are you are you okay me.
Give me comms real quick.
I'll take the Evo.
I could take the Evo.
I've got to get it.
Okay, okay.
Got it.
We got blue now.
I'd go on to, we go up on Storm near scaling up.
We're going right now.
I'll scan up and we're going up.
Okay.
We're good.
Nice.
We survived!
I did not have a chance to get a lot of meds, though.
It's okay.
We don't really have most.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Good job.
We'll hit these Speekings, too.
extra meds anywhere.
I need like, I'm gonna try to find the last.
The last, let's go.
Not us.
We'll take it.
Yeah, see a shield.
So let me know.
Hopefully, hopefully grab a bat.
Yeah, we should all craft the bat up for sure.
All right, I'm gonna craft a bat then.
Okay, they're on, they're on thunder.
They're on thunder.
That's fine.
I'm looking for him right now.
Kids are fucking idiots.
All right.
We probably can't hit the people scan, but craft the
battery.
I can like smoke it maybe.
Um, do it.
Yeah, they're running a far right.
We're good.
Yeah, yeah, we should be able to now.
That's gonna be an echo HQ zone.
Yeah, they're running back there.
Oh, look at all these.
How many evas do you have?
Do we know?
I have one.
We have three.
We all have three.
We want to grab any, like we want to grab what?
That one?
Yeah, probably.
Let's try that.
Let's grab that last eva.
Okay.
just land on it all right and we have another bad 16 cells
um i have oh i have six bad oh i have you have seven bats
does anyone need extra bats i'll take one yeah yeah what the
fuck how do i get seven i'm gonna land over here yeah yeah
you can yeah you're good you should not be over there we
want to walk in just get to echo somewhere but echo's pretty
taken right now actually only two spots taken we can
probably find somewhere to go getting in the middle of echo
wouldn't be bad either okay who wants bats who needs bats uh
i'll take some in this house i'll drop it here i dropped two
bats yeah i'm gonna take one where do you want to grab one
oh i'll take one yeah i have one right now yeah you no you
grab the one that's there i left one there thanks buddy
appreciate it okay now the next room all right we're gonna
try to keep rotating in guys all right we're gonna get to pi
one here there was no one really in pi one so we keep
walking on all right do you say any extra syringes let me
know i only have two okay nice i got it right now four yeah
us here earlier but i don't see them now so keep on
following me we are blue though we're good okay i feel like
tempo has played a lot better since getting off of the roofs
i agree yeah i feel like we've done a lot better now that
he's not there i think the roofs were definitely the problem
without a doubt yes yeah i don't know what you're talking
about what all right i see another evac tower here oh not to
make it or mine i'm gonna scan this we can look this up a
little bit more and we're gonna we're gonna keep walking on
this left side tree line we're gonna evac from here okay and
this we want to grab that thing right on the left yeah yeah
yeah correct
and try to see if there's anything i should take yeah so
right now i'm pretty good there's another 3x i think three
times yeah i'm gonna get this emocash i think i'm good i
need like a stock if you guys find an extra top pylon i
don't see anyone we want to rotate we should go top pylon
right now and actually and i hit that ring console there's
no one up there all right Okay.
Scatted then just in case.
I am.
Yeah, I can be like, oh, you want to stop in here.
I'm scanning.
That one's here.
I'm gonna take the height of it right now.
Hey, I'm...
There's a digi here?
I'm downstairs.
I'm about to scan the thing.
What is it?
What is it on?
I'm gonna craft another badge.
It's down here with me.
Okay, cool.
Wait, wait.
What?
You're good.
I'm left.
Don't left.
We're good.
We should be close to us.
I heard something for sure.
I'm coming to you, Wade.
I hear him.
I hear him underneath it.
They're running away.
Okay, they are.
They are?
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
I'm going to scan it.
Yeah, yeah, definitely scan it for sure.
Yeah, we might use your E-back tower.
I see them.
Little armor.
Yeah, they're a little armor.
Crack one?
She's on here too.
Hmm.
What is free?
Is there a player scan we can hit?
No.
We should just go over here and take a risk.
We're going to make a risk, okay?
All right.
I mean, we do have read a play.
Yeah, we're going to take a risk here.
I have no idea what's free, but we're going to find out.
19 squads up, though.
It's a little bit scary.
I can't lie.
All right.
You're good?
It's fine.
I could smoke us too.
Yeah, we should be good.
I don't think these guys will shoot us off.
Pretty stupid to waste their time doing this to us.
I'm ready.
Yeah, we're going to read a boy here.
I don't have one, so whenever you guys put it up.
Okay, ready?
All right, so wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, we're going to try to, we're going to try to land
something over here.
Okay.
Just follow my lead.
I have no idea what's for you and we're going to find out.
Yep.
We're going to find out.
Don't shoot me.
Wait, we can't go over this way.
It doesn't reach.
We're idiots.
Go this way.
ile go back down go back down go back down go back down go
straight back down yes right and then i'd rather wait for
the zone close and then we just play f9 one more time yes
yes for some reason i thought you could read a play over
there i swear to god i've watched people read a play i'm
just gonna wait for now i remember when We're doing hide and
seek and then they they try to redeploy from there and it
didn't reach so one of the seekers died in zone Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah.
That's fucking hilarious.
It's the same thing too.
It was right here Yeah, I should probably know we can't be
back here On me on me, I guess I probably should know those
things talking about you probably should have actually Yeah,
Mr. Watch.
Oh, I almost fell.
It's good.
Wait, I can't climb up this.
What?
Are you doing a zone read?
Yeah, we're gonna wrap this closer yeah i look i look north
east side i look east side there's there's no one next to
this pack we want to get this pack too you guys stay up here
i'm gonna go this pack okay okay i'm looking at east side
i'm gonna watch over you or try to from here okay we should
be good there's no one over here i don't think i'm watching
top hill so i don't see anybody on east side yeah we should
be fine for some reason we're the only team going to buy one
right now which i understand why you're clear so far i'm
looking up the hill for you you're good buddy got a wingman
i'm definitely taking it right anyone need a two times or
anything or now um i do and you can bring it over i'll take
it yeah gotcha or something i have you're still clear yep
yep i got eva off that too nice huge are you almost red big
uh no no no definitely not even closer still 1900 off okay
that side's still clear there's nobody on east side i hear
people fighting in the prowler section yeah that's actually
good though Yeah, because they're almost going to have to
come to us.
Yeah, that's fine.
I'm going to go down and get ready to scan.
Yeah, go for it.
Doki, here's your two times opponent.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll grab it.
Yeah, you're good.
Light ammo too if he has need.
I'm sure.
I'm looking at our east side still and also the north side a
little.
Okay.
The Wrangler alt at the north.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see them coming over.
They're starting to come over.
Yeah, they're definitely going to fight over there and just
come this way.
It's fine.
I think we just let them.
We can't get that quick enough.
All right, we see that sound, but I was straight echo.
100% are we going?
All right, definitely.
I need to go now for sure.
All right, I'm heading over.
We're going to back this way then.
Okay, we're going to evac around the mountain.
Evac around the brown tree.
Yeah, that's, that's what I was thinking.
Yeah, yeah.
We're gonna have to we're gonna have to this time.
I don't see anyone down below.
This is our last evac.
Well, I didn't see anyone here when you were looting the
pack.
Okay.
So I think so there's like this little corridor over here, I
want to try to get to.
You know what I'm talking about?
A little tunnel in there.
Yeah.
I want to try to land in that tunnel just put traps down and
smoke immediately.
Okay.
So put an evac right here smoke ourselves or smoke the enemy
smoke ourselves right when we land there I'll go first so
you guys know where to land We'll see though.
It might there might be a team there, so I'm gonna find out
when we land in there Oh, they're shooting it back now, bro.
Oh, no, we're not we're not.
We can't no Fucking cringe man.
I don't think we yeah.
What do we want to do?
We don't have any back now, right?
We don't know.
Yeah, no, that was our last one.
That's so bad for us.
I mean, we're technically Is there anyone is there anyone
over here?
I'm not sure our team just landed far right side.
kid shooting at you back is so cringe i'm gonna go look in
this bench for an evac once i can stay here okay i'm looking
behind us just in case i can't design if we don't have an
evac this is so i really fucked us over that first one
that's so cringe all right watch your back from pylon i'm
watching watching i'm watching right now there's a guy
running where i'm pylon no no no no no uh no it's in front
of tempo in front of us i'm looking behind us now there's a
there's a team in pylon though they're gonna come over to
the side we're gonna have to try to kill these guys when
they rotate it okay really where i don't see them over here
over here they're gonna be Okay, I don't see him still.
They're gonna come this way though for sure.
I'll play down a little bit more and walk up to you guys.
I don't want these kids to get covered here.
Yeah, you're good, you're good.
They're gonna rotate over here.
They're gonna play just in pylon.
I saw one guy at least.
It might just be more than one.
But they're shooting your traps out right now.
They're top pylon.
I just hope I don't get shot from behind.
I see what I see.
They're running that's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
We want to fight this.
We do not want these kids to live.
I'm looking now.
They just scanned Beacon?
That's fine.
so they're gonna rotate in on this right side temple you're
going out of zone by the way so yeah so that's enough we
need to try to get a knock when they cross right there
they're here yeah we're here yeah i see how much him i see
us too it's actually so bad for us just because this team on
the top canning could 100 rotate and kill us here yeah
they're on this box behind this car what color armor do you
know purple purple purple yeah okay we're gonna have to just
3v3 these guys i don't have an all-deep solar now um nope no
i don't This is so bad for us.
Fuck me.
I have all here, though.
Yeah, you're good.
Straight to the roof.
I think we just have to late rotate in the zone, boys.
I'm going to be honest.
I think we're just dying.
But they're getting shot at from another team.
Yeah, no team's holding them.
Yeah, another team shot them.
There's one guy behind that tree, though.
He's by himself.
Yep, yep.
Where's this other squad at?
Can we make it around the zone if we need to?
Yeah, we can.
I think we're going to have to, like, get late and just walk
in.
Hopefully all these guys just forgot about us, to be honest.
I don't know if they I think they finished the fight
already.
I don't know.
I don't know They're not shooting anymore.
They're not shooting each other.
I'm not sure.
I ulted us up to the left But come to me guys.
Come to me.
Come to me now.
Come to me now We're gonna cross over the zone.
We're gonna cross over.
I have a dog just fucking arc.
I I'm gonna get hit by like three bang olds.
Me too.
I might be hit by this too.
I'm dead.
I'm dead to the zone I'm just gonna buy five.
I got five five five five.
I'm way quick.
Yeah, I'm stick.
I'm stick.
I altered them too.
Yeah, you're vibing.
so but they all they secure no way oh these pitts are still
sitting here man no way i'm getting ran off like this bro oh
my god if we have an evac this is not like playing valck man
we had three we had three evacs too that's the worst we are
we only used two what was the third one oh i'm not the day
yeah yeah yeah yeah they have an evac we should i think we
had the back here that was the corner well no they could
have got that they could have shot that out too they just
were too distracting on my loot box uh i just didn't expect
the team to be playing on the cannon right there man the
team no no no oh wait no wait unless oh they're dead yes
thank fucking god i hope you die honestly this is the team i
don't mind i wish to kind of live the other squads a bunch
of idiots all right so we got we got one point from that
though man oh my god look at all these needs jesus christ no
way no we're definitely we're definitely gonna play valke
though on world's edge okay okay we need some back up here
back there's in our chat swing
that's i'm back did you entertain our chat no what why not i
was commuted the whole time I'm so sad that team just played
cannon and shot an evac tower out instead of power toys and
rotate that's mind-blowing Yeah, and then they let the other
team behind us rotate Why can they rotate and not us they
had zero benefit of shooting our evac out?
They literally had nothing that was so dumb like fuck these
people I think we had more than one team shoot us because
the evac tower died so fast.
I was all three of them just shooting it.
Oh Which makes no sense because us evacking is better for
them like i don't understand why the fuck they're shooting
our evac out because they're like fuck that team and they
knew it was us they had what they actually said was what
shoot evac i have no idea how to play the game correctly i
think they said that
oh that's the specific words out of their mouth do we say
this is round two challenges i don't think anybody knows how
to play in during round two bro that's your wingman yeah it
is that's gun and he's whipping every shot he's missing
every shot with it my gosh bro bro i don't bro that's sad no
wonder he's still in challenger circuit damn yeah so are we
though so are we though guys so are we i mean we did i mean
we did die before them we did die before that first part is
we would have been so saving the spot i wanted to go to i'm
so sad every time every time that's just why Why we're
literally leaving your back.
Why do you not want us to rotate?
What are you doing?
They're like, what if we get that three extra KP though?
And they got literally none of it But like when it is when
it's all it's all about the possibilities
My chats got to the part where we fucked up our redeploy
I guess I'm just so easy you're still like fucking Valcoving
over the house.
Oh, there's no we were gonna i thought we were wrapping
around the mountain well to be fair we wouldn't have reached
the spot i wanted to if we had to wrap it on the mountain
side yeah but then we could have extra redeploy no we would
have fucking landed on somebody for sure i mean we could
have maybe we're made to work but yeah i thought we were
going around and i was i was like all right i'm ready to go
like halfway around and then i had to turn back to be fair
though there's just no world where that team would sure you
back out and i would just go past them we should have let
tempo be free and just see what happens we really need i
could i could have added to zone i could We should have let
him be free and just see what happens.
I would be in a tree right now.
Spit it.
Man, he should have climbed up a tree and then we would have
been top five.
That could have been us.
Like all these teams were fighting and then we were in that
top five.
Oh, these are an all-volar team.
What?
This is what we're in right now is actually exactly right
next to I want to go.
I'm so sad, man.
Oh, that could have been us.
I'm so...
I could have been us.
That could have been us.
I'm so sad.
It's a horrible cat wall too.
What the fuck are we doing?
What if why is he playing cat?
Is cat metal?
Cat's on bad right now.
It's alright.
I don't know what's meta.
Oh, fish so dead.
Yeah, I don't think they're gonna live this.
Yeah, they're definitely not.
Yeah, they're definitely, that team definitely is not first.
GG's.
Yeah!
We're not second though.
Oh, man.
Love that for us.
We're doing it.
The one point.
We can pretend to be that team.
True.
Spent.
Spent and spend.
We are going to be.
We're going to be like 15th probably.
Probably in.
Yeah.
15th, 16th.
Yeah, somewhere around there.
Yeah, without a doubt.
Yeah, 100%.
We should really only be like five points ahead, so.
Yeah.
We just need a good last two games.
We just need to get to zone, bro.
Yeah, we need to be at the hardest thing about challenge
circuit is all the dumbasses that play edge That's the
hardest thing.
Yeah, a lot.
There's a lot of teams play edge in this one.
I think I left my team All right, I am waiting for this
person I don't know who this person I'm always worried I
accidentally rejected somebody to actually know because so
many people just randomly add me And like I don't reject I
just straight up block I blocked so much.
I blocked 100% friends.
Without a doubt, I definitely blocked friends.
I think somebody who was in my team for one of the
tournaments added me.
But I was like, who is this fucker?
And then I actually blocked.
And after I blocked them, I was like, wait, they were on my
team.
That's so funny.
That is so ridiculous.
All right.
We are, yep, exactly.
14.
And 10th is 4.
away from us exactly exactly what we thought we'd have
playing i'm playing i'm up world such i'm playing uh okay
okay not bloodhound i blood yeah yeah okay let me make sure
my banner represents correctly what i am as a player so i'm
gonna be honest where are we going on this map we don't even
know right yeah we'll figure it out don't even know oh the
badges we'll just type we'll just type ciphon to start with
the badges aren't fixed yet i will guarantee those No, we
can just, I can just type the thing again.
You won't play, you won't get invited to any tournaments.
That's cool.
That's good.
It always works.
Feds always work.
That's good.
Threatening other people.
That's a good thing to do.
Yeah.
Are we good people, guys?
Let's start threatening more.
Yes.
Are we?
Are you?
Okay.
Yes.
Maybe not you, but yes.
Wait, what about me?
Why?
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe not you, but yes.
what what did i do it's got to be nicer man yeah wait you
got it you got to type i'm not the one that's threatening
people also lobby codes out yeah oh we're in don't worry oh
wait hey guys you guys know the lobby code it's out every
fucking time no did you guys know that the lobby kill
someone's signing tissue tissue yay so far so good i believe
in us i always do
all righty what's the worst that could happen i mean we
should i think we're i think we might be free here i'm not
sure yeah we'll see not free though there's nowhere we can
really swerve that's the only problem we can swerve tree is
still open tree and harvester are still open i'm
crossing off as i see people post stuff is it still open yep
yay
okay we got this yeah we can we can we can still just in
case we can still swerve harvester and treat that's fair i'm
down for that actually that's pretty good we got this i
believe i totally believe in us this is this is where we got
all of our points yeah yeah yeah exactly world's edge is
where we got a lot of our points this is it which okay
so lava siphon and we swerved a tree it wouldn't be that bad
we can make that work we just really need to focus on
getting this fucking into zone We're literally just
guaranteed to fucking call just need a beacon.
It's just it's just avoiding the bullshit, man It's it's so
hard for us to do that sometimes and that situation We 100%
could have we had a Val can we get in the zone and probably
get top five But it's really fucking hard when the evax is
getting shot out for no reason that situation.
Yeah That's a lows We're better at world's edge than we are
on That we're a world's edge storm point.
Yeah, we're a world's edge team.
That's us.
We'll never we'll never figure out storm point But that's
okay all right for some reason we're a world-side squad
we're a world-side squad that's us
i love these guys are talking about these guys are talking
about fucking rainbow six dude bro i don't think they're
locked in man i swear if these guys which team is it i don't
know okay they are which team which team i swear if they're
talking about rainbow six siege and they're higher ranked
than us i don't know i don't guys i don't know i think we
No, we're good.
We're good.
I'm listening to fucking no hands right now.
We're so locked in we're so I thought that we're supposed to
be better this time to the floor Are we supposed to be
better gamers this time around?
Uh, no, we're doing good.
We're doing good.
We're actually in a pretty good.
We just got top 15 both games in a row That's pretty good
actually last week.
We got like 19th in the second game and then like 19th again
I think and then the last game we also got 19th last game
last week no okay no last week we got two games where where
we didn't place very well but we still got top 12 yeah yeah
until last game too we're good we're in a better we're in a
better streak already i thought we're 14th right now yep
yeah which is better but through two games last week we were
not at 14 we were at 14th only because of one game though oh
yeah yeah yeah we got second place and then we got like 19th
19th 19th okay we just need to repeat that we need to repeat
that exact scenario we need to go find our v we need to find
an rv guys guys yes you're understanding a little bit this
is good yes yeah yeah we figured it out where no one can
shoot us because we don't have the firepower for this
exactly we're a strategic team we're not a shooting team let
me let me go plug in evan's Hello.
Wait, what are you trying to say about his controller, bro?
Wait, what about what?
You cheating?
You're plugging the house controller so you can get to the
store.
There's a special thing on there, you know?
Yeah, on the back of it.
Yeah.
I thought it was a rumble pack, but it wasn't.
He downloaded a program for it or what?
All right.
Don't worry.
I'm ready for Bloodhound.
All right.
So siphon into tree or harvester if we need to spread.
Bro.
I can't believe my ring badge is still not back yet.
Or do we just contest Siphon?
You know?
TSM buff?
We have the TSM buff.
We contest Siphon, we win.
No, I don't think I want to do that.
I don't think I want...
Because I don't know if I want to contest anybody.
Why do we not have Beacon again?
I don't know.
Okay, so if we need...
If someone is going Siphon and we need to swerve...
I want to kill Tree.
Just kill Tree.
Tree has Beacon and everything.
Yeah, Tree has Beacons.
Someone's going tree.
I think there is.
Okay.
Is there?
No, there's no one here.
Okay.
I'm going to loot at the bottom.
Wait, actually, no, I should loot here.
I have to go loot the center because of the thing.
I'll loot the bottom.
I got bottom.
Great.
Yo, I bet you no one went siphoned because they thought we
were going there.
I'm going to rotate through that.
That's fine.
Also, fuck them.
They don't get the damage.
I can do loot.
And nobody gets siphoned.
We're looting two POIs.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
There's no point.
Streamer advantage.
Don't scan until it's done.
it's fine i'd actually rather just land tree anyway because
the beacons dude i'm not going to go lava siphon with no
beacon it's useless to us what is our luck though landing
lava siphon not getting a beacon why is your round two worse
than why our luck should be better round two than round one
never we actually have the worst round fucking the worst
round two ever and my loot is fucking awful oh my god devo
and a mastiff i don't like this my does that at least does
the bot that you shot down at least have a key no i don't
think so oh my god this is a i'm ready to no it's gonna have
no name i think no name or blue bins one of two it's okay
i'm ready to rotate yeah we should rotate i'm gonna leave
this backside house we just go okay do we go to back to
siphon we are gonna to the bridge okay go for it yeah i'm
gonna go it's okay if i die then my teammates were dog shit
oh i don't know if that's how that works out that's not how
that works wait don't you looted this whole place and didn't
grab the harvester oh i i didn't see it the evil thing
didn't show up oh my god she's not locked in okay you can't
say that because i'm did not pop up when i was looting that
you cannot blame me on that it literally did not did not
open
that was not my fun i'm gonna go up this zip thingy i
literally didn't pop up here we're separating pretty far
guys guys if you said there's no one there so i'm fully
trusting my igl no well i said there's probably no one lava
i have no idea i'm gonna take if i die and we don't rotate
like that okay great thank you so much do you want to scan
the people beacon wait we should scan stuff yeah yeah i'm
gonna go to people beacon i'm going to oh my gosh Wait,
wait, I saw a trail.
I saw a trail this way.
You see that?
No, I did not look at it.
The red, the red, there's a red trail over there.
Okay.
I'm going to go inside with you.
Here, I dropped the gold.
Okay.
I'll take that.
Thank you.
Yeah, why not?
W.
Wait a minute.
Was there anyone in the, where did you see that thing?
Was it in the red?
It was like a, I saw a red trail taking the redeploy, and
then they flew this direction.
But I don't know if they flew inside of the building or
what, or they flew.
this way i don't i couldn't tell i'm gonna move up and check
like i couldn't tell the direction right now i'm heading
over i'm gonna take lava damage just for you guys thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you oh i tried to get on
the car it didn't work it's okay buddy okay let me know when
i can do the people scan we're gonna figure that out right
when you get over here we'll see does someone need a 2x uh i
do if you don't need it yeah we're good i don't see anyone
here should we look at the people should we good okay i'm
gonna risk my life do it do it the gold mag here villain
because my teammate told me to i got you trust me you let's
see nobody oh yeah oh yeah we need to keep going we need to
get going what the fuck is going on a monument all right
come through over here we're gonna we're We're gonna get up
through choke right now.
We're gonna get topside guys with choke.
All right.
Lava seven choke, we're good.
Someone, or I have, I have, what the fuck?
I have four cells.
Just five more cells.
I have cells too.
We're good.
I have four bats though, so.
Blue bag, no one needs.
All right, we're gonna hit this.
We're gonna hit this tower in front of us.
Yeah.
And we're gonna get top of the guys with lava seven choke.
Okay.
Where TSM normally plays, all right?
I'm ready.
All right, go for it, hit the shit.
We got it.
Right here, Ducky on the right.
I know, I just wanted to look at that bird.
I was waiting for you anyway.
Okay, okay.
I had to go grab a bat.
Okay.
They're trying to take it from us.
We need to go.
Where are they?
They're down below?
They're trying to take it from us.
Swords her back.
We can't.
We gotta go back.
Okay, yeah, they're further.
God damn it.
Fuck me.
Where do they come from?
Yeah, we're gonna play from Glourmas.
We need to move in a little bit more though.
I want to play from here.
I want to get to Zone.
We're not gonna be able to get this zone from here.
That's so fucked.
Fuck me.
we go around from the geyser side you know what let's see
what yeah there's a team in there right now okay that sucks
let's see this team in lava simon choked moves i don't know
if they're gonna hold it or not damn we were like half a
second earlier we've been good where's the geyser team
they're in next to geyser like the actual geyser itself they
were in there oh see okay i think this team might have moved
up a little bit we're gonna go up here and scan okay i think
this They left the choke completely So we're gonna walk up.
We're gonna scan Get to like right here and scan and then
just if they're up there just stay on your mountainside and
you're gonna go Scouting yeah, nope.
I could take take take take take take take take take take
I'm going up I'm going up as well as well We'll let my IGL
go up further.
Yeah, yeah, let me go for a reason there.
I see a res Yeah, we're fine right now.
Um 53 seconds ago.
There's a gas canister here.
Yeah, there's gonna be a team on the right side guys are
showed There's definitely a team over here.
Oh, I just got scammed.
Yeah.
From the choke, good.
All good.
East side.
We're good.
We're chilling.
I'm just going to heal this.
Go for it.
We have a redeploy if we want to use it.
Yeah.
I just don't know where this is going to pull.
This might pull back.
We just stay here for right now and we go.
I'm watching.
I'm watching behind us.
We'll watch front then.
Yeah.
You watch front, Doki.
Just make sure you don't get ratted on.
They can 100% creep up.
Just play from here and we can evat.
We get valkal delay if we need to.
Or evac.
it's not a bad spot because this could this could be a wonky
pool i don't really trust this pool at all okay i'll wait
until they're scanned yeah yep sure fun also if the zone
does pull down i'm pretty sure big house is not taking yet
to point out tambo you keep looking behind us down below
okay i'm looking siphon yeah yeah you do that i'm gonna
scope this you know i'm gonna make sure scanning yeah just
keep on scanning that's good job there is a team siphon uh
i'm looking at
We hold these kids out no matter what that's for sure.
Wait, someone just hit a beacon.
How was that noise?
Someone just hit a ring console.
Right here, what the fuck?
Wait, what the fuck?
Is he just in the open?
I don't know, he just hit a ring.
I just heard a ring console and a guy in front of me.
Careful temple where we backed up.
Blue armor, by the way.
Yeah, I don't know what the fuck that was.
I just heard a ring console and then that guy was in front
of me.
What?
What about a bug?
Yeah, you're good.
They're going through blue bit and we're fine.
Okay.
They're leaving us.
Are you still looking?
Okay.
You're still looking behind.
I see them.
Yeah.
I'm currently trying to fight us real quick.
Where the fuck is the spot you're trying to play, buddy?
Just leave.
Leave us.
We're content.
I don't know why they're trying to hold you.
The spot's so bad.
Once they have the, unless they think the sound is on.
Remember, this is round three.
Oh my God.
Okay.
What's that?
Oh, yo.
Yeah.
I'm scanning.
Watch out.
Yeah.
Tempo.
here yeah yeah jockey got to step a little bit more and just
keep scanning and show presence i know no no no no oh that
look i can't hold on how are they pushing this bro i'm
batting this what am i watching right behind us behind us
what the bro we're getting grieved man we are what am i
watching right now we've got cost to go with it what is my
savior my savior
Oh, we're so dead.
Temple, just hide.
Just hide.
Temple, just hide in there.
There's another team is pushing forward, too.
Just hide.
You don't exist.
Why did we get creeped?
No, genuinely, what the fuck am I playing, bro?
Oh, my God.
I don't
know.
It's another time for it.
These kids are so fucking bad, man.
Bro, just stay in the house.
That's your home now, Tempo.
Oh, my God, bro.
This is the shit.
That tells me and just don't pay too much.
Oh my God.
I'm safe.
Don't worry, guys.
I can get your banner.
I can get your banner and then Evac Tower.
Banner, Evac, and I'm good.
And I have a Moby right here.
Just get us one point.
I actually cannot believe what I'm talking about.
How was that team able to push from Blue Bins?
Why are they pushing from Blue Bins?
What are you doing?
These are why these kids stay hard to challenge a circuit
for 98 years.
Holy fuck dude.
I agree.
98.
Oh my god.
How is this possible?
Why in one world are they able to push up like that?
That is crazy.
Tempo.
Is that P20 I see in your hand?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was looking for a re.
No, I have hammer points.
It's okay.
I believe.
No one's gonna go in your house.
There's no way.
Just stay there.
Don't even fucking get out of, don't even leave.
You just stayed.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
It's pulls right on top.
Does it pull on the choke?
Oh my god.
It does, bro.
It pulls out here.
And we just got grief so hard.
You know, you know, you know the old zone with the pills and
shit?
Yeah.
Exactly.
So it's going to be the blue bench one.
We literally called it perfectly.
And we just got grief from two fucking.
Oh my god.
We got grief so hard.
All right, guys.
I think it was a nade.
They saw you got nade in.
They're like, this is it.
This is it.
It's just in any good lobby.
that team just cannot move they just cannot push from blue
bits like it doesn't mean yeah they got grief for that let's
just hope that team doesn't try how many gas cans can you
have out six wait i'm maxed out i'm maxed out yeah okay
wouldn't be funny let's just throw a nade and activate all
six of these that's why yep that's why i have a nade for
counteractivate wig as the rat now it's tempus time to shine
all you need to do is get to 15th so we get that plus one no
i have a need i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna win i believe i
have a need i'm gonna get to third and i'm gonna need them
as they three p each other oh no guys where did that scam
come from.
I have no fucking clue.
Are they behind you?
Maybe?
Well, we were fucking like strategizing the one blood house
scan to end it all, to find out you're a rat.
You're so fucked.
No, you're a rat, bro.
Wait, I can, I can evac out of here.
You got this, man.
Nothing but positivity here.
Guys, we need one more team to die.
One more team to die.
One more.
That's all we need.
That's all the bad is behind you, is behind you.
to be from up there right it came from behind didn't it i
swear it came from behind i wish we can ping when we're dead
i wish that was a feature maybe they'll miss the scan if i'm
just died there's easy dogs bro i feel it i can feel it but
i can feel that top 15.
i do too yeah yeah we just need we literally need one team
one more team to die while this really closes i would not
push you like i'll be real seven barrels deep a fart bomb
like i need i think you get this top oh yes let's go i feel
like that team might push you oh that's two different flood
hounds okay hey oh my god yeah okay pulls there as soon as
these guys pass me i can eat i can as soon as these guys
walk out past me i can late evac from out here and then just
and then just go in a circle holy this is a terrible zone
this is literally open Well, to be fair, the team Bluebeen
should have been dead.
The fucking Geyser team should have shot them the whole
fucking time they're walking up on us.
Like, what are they doing?
Are they touching themselves?
Like, I understand.
Bro, the homies gotta, you know, relieve the other homies
stress.
Yeah, they're so stressed out.
These guys are running past.
You need ultis.
You need to stay alive for top 12.
I don't know.
I think they're running past.
Um, they are not running past.
They are not running past.
They want that.
Oh, you bitch.
Yeah.
Fuck them up.
Tempo top time, baby.
Come on.
18 million barrels you can't get in here oh I don't know man
top 10 you're so close keep barreling keep barely just do
like a non-stop barrel act yes 100 there's no way that's the
barrel act of 2024 oh my god shoot your middle shoot your
middle oh my god they're gonna keep doing that nice nice top
10 yes top 10 i fucking get a challenger circuit good job
well played man good job you're probably going to no this
team is gonna all day they stole your evac they're stealing
my plan they stole your whole plan i hope i hope they die
off this evac yeah i hope you fucking fly into a mountain
and die oh my god you could have died there that was you you
would have died you would have died there's no way bro if
you here.
We got one team came up here, two teams came up here, and
then we just got fucking full-time.
That could have been you.
They stole your team back.
I think you're a really good spot where they landed, but I'm
not gonna lie, that's a good job.
That one could have been us, man.
That could have been fucking tempo.
We got top 10.
Was that two points for top 10?
I think so.
Nice.
We got plus 2.
Okay, last game, guys.
We need to have a really good game.
Yeah, that's for damn sure.
Or I don't think we're making it.
not going to get griefed in round two or what the fuck going
on our round two is never lucky we're lucky in round one the
fucking round that never matters like this is bullshit this
is bullshit dude it's that i call for a recount i demand a
revote yeah i would demand this particular game to be reset
i agree i think they i think they bring us back to the exact
same circle restart the game we go from there yeah yeah yeah
that's the only fair way to put you not want more content
We're literally boosting the Challenger Circuit views right
now
It's so crazy to say You guys like I Why do you want the
content to be good?
I bet you I have the most viewers on YouTube right now for
Challenger Circuit You need me for the YouTube
representation We need me for the viewership Come on Come
on, Tees, you gotta let us, we have to, we're here to save
Apex.
So we can go Siphon, by the way.
Yeah, I mean, yeah, we can, but if there's no beacon, I
don't even wanna go there.
That's true, all right.
Okay.
So we've got two POIs.
Yeah, we have two POIs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Realistically, this last game should be good for us.
All I'm saying, let us through the round three and we'll
give you more content.
Best case scenario, we're in 12.
Okay, that's definitely not gonna happen for sure.
gonna happen we will probably stay in 14 which means we need
like a 10 point game okay all right that's all right which
is doable that's that's second place and one kill that's
easy oh oh i you saw that conduit oh and then oh and then he
he still hit himself oh my god oh no
bro this guy's a 4k badge what the bro what the am i
watching oh yo you You know what I should have done?
I should have when that team was coming in, I should have
given them the evac.
Yeah, they would have left.
And then they would have left and now I would have been
like, all right, see you guys.
Yeah, but then you would have just died on the walk up.
Yeah, you would die on the walk.
I'm not going to lie.
You needed that evac.
Oh, no, no, I take it after them.
I pretend like we're four people on a team.
I should have colluded.
I feel like you'd be the one.
Yeah, we should have all four of us should have taken the
balloon.
I should have just thrown it out for them and then been
like, truest.
Yeah, but I think they just threw it out for them they the
other team would have shot the evac because there was there
was there was no way they would have fucking not shot it
yeah it would have been a truce what do you mean no i meant
the other team the other other team yeah but then they would
see four of us and get scared well no they'll see the evac
tower and shoot it down like what i'm confused okay jesus
this is it oh my god I'm so watching that conduit do some
amazing things.
Conduit 838326.
Guys, I thought that we're a world's edge team.
What happened to us?
We used to be...
I mean, we just got grief, guys.
We used to be such a good team.
Teams around us have no brain cells.
I called the zone perfectly.
I literally knew exactly where it was going.
And we had Geyser Choke doing a fucking team jerkoff instead
of fucking shooting the squad.
We should have been in the house.
It's true.
Temmix was probably through the roof for them, though, bro.
I'm going to be honest.
If that team that was on those boxes, the blue bins, lived,
I swear to God, I'd be so sad.
I'm pretty sure they did.
They did?
No.
Geyser Choke did nothing.
Those guys were awful.
Yeah, Geyser didn't do anything.
Yeah, but I'm thinking like the other team behind them.
That's what you would think.
For sure.
No, for sure.
They just don't.
They don't know what they're doing.
Yeah, that's right.
That's what he meant.
i have no idea who the okay oh wait no that is them wait no
it's a wraith team wraith caustic bloodhound team i haven't
seen a wraith caustic bloodhound team at all
someone was like in my chat what if it's the tsm tag that's
giving you okay let's remove our tsm tag let's remove it and
see if we get better
right it's the tag it's the tag curse it'll be funny i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna just literally say to that chat
guys are choked we jerking each other off or what do it do
it do it do it do it all right okay i'm taking off the tsm
tag guys we got fired from tsm we are oh we only dropped one
rank we're in 15.
oh it's to the bat how far are we up seven points oh yeah
Okay.
All right.
So yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's not bad at all.
Seven points.
We had 10 point game.
We're definitely back in it.
Yeah.
I got rid of TSM.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
Let's go.
Guys, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
12, 9, 7.
We need, we need third and three kills.
Easy.
Nice.
Yeah.
It's so easy, guys.
We have two POIs.
We can't fuck this up.
Yeah, exactly.
There's no way.
Yeah.
Oh, I'll just type code in chat.
Oh, I like that actually.
That would be so funny, but we will not.
Your loadout was crazy, bro.
P20 charge rifle is nuts.
Yeah, that's what I was saying.
I was like, is that P20?
I don't think that makes it better.
There were so many big guns on the ground when I passed, it
was crazy.
Wait, hammer doesn't make it better.
No way that makes it better.
I was also looking for a read.
That's why.
fair fair fair how do you not find a re that's so weird
that's like one of the whoever guys are choke choking each
other guys i'm in the lobby now we're good i'm here you guys
know the lobby codes out yes oh yeah we're in here we're in
here by the way we're in all right guys 10 point game let's
do this all right template game easy never lost template
game this is it this is it we got this this is it i believe
in this situation bro you're go for that we can do this 40
barrels down i feel like i feel like could if that team just
left me alone i feel like i could have flew and then landed
somewhere and just wrapped jammed all the way to the third
challenge your circuit no one no team actually thinks for
themselves They rely on feelings, not...
Yo, you know what?
They should make it.
And then we can play Pathfinder.
They should make it so Pathfinder can't be scanned because
he's a robot.
What the fuck?
True.
Yeah, because then we could just play Pathfinder and no one
would scan us.
Yeah, but then the rest of us can get scanned.
Oh, no.
When we're ratting.
Oh, when the rat has to rat.
Yeah, when the Pathfinder has to rat, basically.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I see.
Great job fighting to that team who tried to fight us
leaving Geyser.
I got you.
Yeah, that means I think that's us.
Whoever Geyser.
Wait, what were you saying?
They were beating each other off in the Geyser room?
The Geyser choke?
Yeah.
Were we at the Geyser choke?
We were not at the Geyser choke.
Oh, no, but the team Geyser choke didn't shoot the Bluebeans
team at all.
I don't know what the fuck they were doing.
Like, in that situation, like, we were, like, definitely
made me need to show more presence in the front.
But that team on Geyser choke should be shooting that
Bluebeans.
the whole time as like the freest kills for both of us i
believe in us guys we can do this there's no way we just
need a really really really good last game no just a just a
semi three three and three isn't that that much of a stretch
this is literally our last game tempo we really need a good
game yeah yeah three and three 12 9 7 that's 10 that's 10
points you know teammate is duo do we just land on them no
yeah we get two free kills no what if another team thirds as
well we there's no way there's no way i bet you this team we
play we play three shooting people or three ability damage
There's no way we're not griefing our last game.
Maggie fuse and oh shoot stuff and Valk.
Maggie fuse and Valk and then we land on the duo.
He wants us to land on the duo.
Maggie, Maggie, Fuse and Valk and we just ability spam team
eight and land on them, late land on them and then get two
free points.
Where do we, where?
God, my head hurts all the time.
Oh, fuck.
I mean, let's just go lava siphon.
Let's go lava siphon, guys.
Let's get a rotation.
We defeat a good endgame, bro.
I don't think you.
We actually can go huge, Ralph.
Yeah, top three, we can qualify.
Bro, you actually broke Wig.
He's just like, did you just say that?
I'm not kidding.
I actually ignored the whole thing.
So I just like heard that.
I heard that.
And I was like, dude, I can't, like, I'm so, locked in to
get this top 10 right now that i just can't think about what
we just said i can't i can't i'm locked we got this we got
this we got this all right we're doing this i believe
let's do it we are a world's edge team yeah yeah yeah yeah
guys don't fucking take my two points that i got in the
first game like oh yeah guys it has to matter it was two
points we don't do anything those two points you did it mean
all yeah like what the i tried so hard i'm bang right or
bloodhound bloodhound i want to point out how good that
would have been for us if we stayed alive that sucks yeah we
got this we got this all
righty whoo locked i'd have to go to the bathroom pretty bad
though all right let's do wait did you not go to the
bathroom just said i did okay i was gonna say yo we got
beacon we got beacon wait my game crashed my game crashed oh
my game for your game because you're still in here so all
that for your game and then reconnect you're what an orange
look we know wait no wait no wait no if you all that for if
you all that for you can get in no no my game like full
crashed yeah just close your entire game and then restart i
just closed the entire game you should really get me should
really get back in okay that was just please please please
please please please please please please please please
please please Please, please.
Please, please, please, please.
No, they're going left.
I thought you can reset.
Please, please, please.
No, what is her luck?
We're good.
No one's landing with us.
I'm going to land her middle.
I'm going to land her middle and punch her in.
I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm
in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in.
I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, yeah, yeah, just hit the
beacons.
Let me get this too.
Okay, I'm going to, is there a team on us?
Is there a team on us?
no no no no no okay i'm gonna loot the inside of this oh my
god that would have been so a way to go out oh my god jesus
christ all right sounds close too we got we get a good
rotation here it's probably gonna be staging side holy me
man that was scary not gonna ask me the fuck out that was so
scary thank god oh my god i got gold helmet though let's go
We have two gold health.
What's huge?
It's huge.
We'll give it to you when we get into town.
It's great
Yeah, I'm gonna look the the far left the far left there's
there's something over there purple stuff I don't know what
it is.
I'll look.
I'll look Guys, I found my re
There's also a bunch of uh evac towers over here if you guys
don't have them You ping it?
Yeah, I got you.
Okay, nice
I have a Do you see a repeater?
Let me know.
Gosh, I'm going to have a Democass over here too.
What do we want?
Top thermal or?
Yeah, it's going to be thermal choke zone for sure.
Or yeah, there's an energy mag here.
I'm going to grab this.
Actually, no, I don't need a repeater anymore.
I have a carbide.
There's a purple heavy mag here.
Someone win thermal will be really good.
I think the two-story buildings will be really good for us.
So we should probably rush immediately if we can.
Okay, I'm coming over then.
cover come over me now guys both of you yeah i'm paying over
now i want to get here fast i don't really want to deal with
the bullshit and try to get a good spot in zone all right
i'm running i'm running yeah yeah come my way i'm running oh
tempo so far it should be fine now there's a charge rifle
here too too bad that's too late i have a sense so i don't
know i also have a vault key if we need something in the end
here maybe maybe let's just go quick i want to try to get
yeah we just move first yeah i think i think those if we get
those two stories we can actually win this game i think it's
gonna pull that way could even go island but regardless you
still gonna play come on get that evac and then i'm running
straight i mean it's in my pathway anyway yeah it's fine no
don't worry you should be able to get it you're chilling all
right i'm good okay uh wait do you need a heavy mech uh no
i'm actually good bro i got a purple one i'm chilling i have
no backpack this is bad it's fine should be fine yeah i
didn't forget now it's all good we're gonna go tree towards
tree and then ulti in actually can i evac if i if i okay
we're gonna try something here we're gonna try some of
something we're gonna come to me oh yeah not here not here
not here not here can i grab that canister yeah go get that
cash go get the cash yeah we're gonna wait for doki anyway
yeah you're showing should be fine yep i'm good so when we
when we slam inside one of these buildings guys it's a
really good chance we're gonna be there so just like stay
together we're gonna literally just try to slam inside one
of the buildings we want to take one okay you're good you're
good I can order me.
Can I go up here and hit this?
I can.
What?
How do I attach to you?
You're good, you're good, you got this.
You're trying to get one of these two stories up here.
It's hard ping.
I'll get, I'll ping.
We're gonna see which one's free though.
One of those buildings, yeah.
Yes, yes, one of these two.
We're gonna try to slam the second floor of this left one,
okay?
This one?
This one, left one.
Okay.
And then right here, then we're going to scan across, and
we're going to try to get the next one.
There's no one, okay?
One second.
A four.
First floor.
I want you to wait.
Okay.
Get upstairs.
That trap down stairs is not mine.
You're good.
Okay, no, no.
No more scans.
Okay.
We're going to wait for this scan.
Are they okay?
Two seconds, three seconds.
Scanning?
getting yep there's no one in the next boat we should go no
nice take this building take this building then come here
what happened to them i don't know they backed up there's
one guy you should himself that's fine yeah all right let's
take this one we're good yeah we're gonna hold this one and
we're chilling guys that's fine great okay nice we're good
set up our floors locked doors down below we're good to go
nice job we have no backpack you said no no i have a lot i
have eight cells one bath so not great like my ammo
situation is not good i'm I feel like I need more ammo
than...
Does anyone want my Phoenix kit?
Oh, no, I'm going back out.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You're gone.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's two up here.
We're trying to get the loot.
Oh, I just realized I have no fucking sight on my sniper
gun.
There's a...
I'll give you my 2x, because I don't think I can shoot
really.
Yeah.
I'll give you my...
Because I literally don't have the ammo to shoot to poke at
all.
Take it before it gets taken.
What'd you need?
I'll keep it kind of ammo.
Well, I have light and energies and 120 each.
just there's a lot of energy there's some more energy down
here i don't have the backpack space i only have two stacks
of each oh here i can get it for you i want to get a few
here it's like yeah you can grab the energy and light here
yeah i got you i'll get the light energy first yeah i
literally don't have the ammo for the for poking here here
we're gonna keep this door close guys just keep this door
close we're gonna take too much damage we don't i have two
bad stick cells i have one phoenix kit one batten uh seven
cells okay i literally could not poke because of the lack of
stuff what's your ammo though just in case all right we're a
little poor all right well i mean we're a little poor now
but i'm not gonna lie our spot's good like
can't can't you like climb up on this thing or something no
i think they patched it in there yeah they used to be able
to because people would people would like rat here and then
like wait until somebody comes in and then shoot them yeah
oh tempo is here as well come here come upstairs take this i
have more important i have my uh oh yeah barrels yeah yeah
you're good just in case i definitely don't need my i
definitely don't need my ulti or my fucking q yeah you don't
need those yeah there's no we can't climb that i'm gonna say
in the bathroom i don't think i can contribute to the team
unless somebody pushes us i can't really do anything either
show it or come to your game that's what this is we have
evacs right yeah Yeah, we have two Evacs and Jockholt, so.
Evac-E-Vac-ing from here.
Anywhere the zone is?
Yeah, I feel like they're shot down.
Good job, though.
Like, honestly, we just got grief last game.
We're actually calling zones, like, pretty good.
We're not doing anything wrong.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just other people ruining our game.
It seems like that's a very common trend for us.
We never do anything wrong.
No, we just need this to pull.
We just need this to pull literally right here.
Yes.
And then we can get top three.
And we can get kill somewhere.
i have three names though it's all we need bro we just need
an end game names and gas yep i have no names with the 10
minute delay no one knows i'm gay now everybody knows so my
chat said that chat not have delay go ahead i don't think he
understood the assignment i don't i'm confused i don't think
he realized what delay means Nothing wrong with it anyway.
Fuck it.
Do you have to hang?
Good job coming out in my chat.
Oh, team playing a fence over there?
All right.
I'm just using the bathroom.
One of your favorite, actually, buddy.
One of your favorite.
Can you take one of these barrels, two of these barrels out,
and put them in the doors in the other building?
Like, block the doors.
Wait, let's see where this team goes first.
Wait, wait, wait.
You army?
They're gonna land on it, I think.
They are.
They are?
another not you're not i don't think so i think you're gonna
do it buddy block their doors all right 100 ammo let's go
like block it from the inside inside yeah like and then come
out the top side so when they land inside they get stuck
outside we can kill them good idea yeah yeah good idea okay
seven more squads please die yeah i got more light ammo for
you a lot more squad give me give me give me i can only eat
like 30 30 of that though or not even i'm stressed out dude
i'm stressed out it's okay as long as we stay in this house
they're not going to do anything we have like caustic alts
we live in the second floor i live in this they're not going
to see me if i live in this bathroom yeah wait do you guys
have do you guys have any nades i know wig has none no zero
okay wait you guys each take a thermite so we can just throw
nades at everyone when they come in they'll never expect it
yeah oh my wait what the up there yeah there's two spots
right here there's another one right here hi well i mean you
shouldn't because i think gigantic head is yeah i feel like
you're kidding i feel like if we i go here they will never
look up they always look at the stairs and i can easily grab
a kill there yeah yeah yeah you do that you do that yeah
yeah yeah i'll be here i'll be here to contribute to my team
do that that's a free day throw should i contribute should i
scan i should scan nobody on the house beside us yeah we
should be good we have the doors blocked off yeah I'm just
going to be praying the sound comes to us if it doesn't
we're dead.
We're so fucked.
Yeah.
Like it somehow pulls all, it might pull like back here.
It could.
It definitely could.
The hell Mary in five seconds.
If it pulls down there.
If it pulls down there, I really don't know what to say
guys.
We had a good run.
We were just never meant to get passed around to maybe next
year.
Do you know what has to do with DC?
Oh.
That's fine.
We stay here.
It's going to end choke.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no, no.
We're standing.
It's pulling back to us.
it's pulling back to us yeah it's it's one of those surprise
motherfuckers oh boy how much you want bet i'll bet a lot of
money it does not so i'll bet zero dollars because it is
baby let's go oh
what is this guy doing he's up here he's showing huh wig i
swear please don't get shot by like three different people
someone might try to find this building right now i got shot
by one yeah like i said called that and you it's Someone
added some trash.
In this building.
Wait, wait.
Come back here.
They can't go first floor because of my traps.
That's fine.
They're going to be fucked.
Don't shoot them.
They activated.
My traps is hurting them.
That's fine.
Just keep this house clean.
Now block our doors.
If you can't bomb the side.
Yeah.
I'm going to scan.
I'm going to scan the house behind us.
I'm going to live here now.
Go for it.
Yo, the fact that these guys are all coming up makes it seem
like.
have no choice they just have no choice they have no choice
they have no choice there's no way there's no way they would
know either there's no way this challenge is yeah they scan
this beacon over here oh oh yeah over here they're on fence
line right now okay now there's two teams okay if these two
teams fight we 100 just kill these guys oh my god look at
this yeah yeah they're calling this hardcore okay should we
have like a barrel on the door or no outside maybe yeah
they're gonna break it they're probably gonna break it out
so yeah they're gonna break it i'll throw one i'll throw one
there anyway since i have some cooldowns they're gonna
forget i'm up on this they're gonna forget i'm up here i bet
you there's no way there's no way they'll remember you're
still right you're still right you're so smart there's no
way it's no way right guys yeah right guys you're gonna
forget there's no way we get three men shot from here Like,
catch your person.
Who does team?
Team full running on the left over here.
Oh, yeah.
You guys can see out the window.
I can.
Look for these kills on the outside.
You want me to help shoot?
Yeah, sure.
Okay.
I'm coming down.
Locked one.
Nice.
Cracked one.
I think they're full dead.
They're all dead.
Everyone died over there.
We got 2KB.
Nice.
tempo we hold our top floor no matter what though okay top
building bottom floor if we need to anything but you're good
right now just don't die for it I'm trying to do I can't do
the climb anymore I'm so close to purple armor I really want
to try to get this I'm gonna try and do it to climb no I
can't do the climb anymore it was so cool when I was able to
do it what are you shooting me for you fucking idiot you
guys are so bad I got it okay scan how many cells and bats y
'all have I have one bat in uh three cells two bats okay
okay they're smoking us just watch our first floor make sure
i'm watching first yeah okay we're good we're good we're
good they don't remember they'll they will never remember
i'm up here never they will never get scammed by 10 million
teams but yeah there's no way they'll remember okay i got
purple armor nice i'm gonna pop a phoenix for this i want to
use it i think i have two bats three cells okay nice all
right nice yeah just the least damage we i thought i'm gonna
be honest i saw a doki up top i thought I was tempo on roof
and I was about to scream.
I'm not even kidding.
How the fuck would he have got to the roof?
There's no way he would have lived.
I was like, tempo!
What the fuck?
Okay.
That's the team on the roof though.
It's okay.
They will never remember me.
No.
Wait, is there a bolt up here that I can take for...
Dude, his mind is gonna fight.
His mind should fight.
We'll see what happens.
They're coming on the outside of us right now.
We're good.
Okay.
The fight underneath is the left.
Yeah, they're over there.
Then one team's behind and one team's up there.
It's safe, but like not really.
When the zone closes in, they should get...
Is there anyone still in that other house or no?
Yeah, there is.
They literally stand.
Yeah.
We need these two teams to fight.
That's what we need.
They're using us as a buffer.
Yeah, it's fine.
That's good.
We're the buffer.
It's fine with me.
Okay.
You want to push us to hide?
You want to be scared?
You can hide.
Tempo come first.
Come second fourth.
Temple.
They need a door.
They need to stand west or east.
I want to be honest.
So scan my side every time.
Scan this way.
Nice.
Oh, that team is gone.
That's fine.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
Yeah.
They're going to play.
Face her hopefully.
They're on our first floor.
Come on.
We're going to fight soon.
They're going to fight soon.
I'm scanning five.
Yeah.
We're zones on us still.
We're good.
We just hold our second floor with everything we have.
I should have met like 50 gifted.
What the fuck?
Don't care.
Tempo, come over here, get another barrel in the balcony.
Get another barrel in the balcony.
You have the shootouts, okay.
It's worth it.
They can't really shoot out that easily.
Okay.
I'm watching the window down here.
We're staying up here.
Are they on the roof right now or now?
No.
Okay, good.
That's great for us.
Let's go ahead.
I don't need it.
I'm good.
Oh, yeah.
We just stay inside.
We literally just don't want to stay inside.
Tempo, can you move this barrel?
This one?
and put it right actually the door right here.
Around the corner.
Nice.
Right here.
A lot of blood.
Yeah, let them do it.
Let them do it.
We're good guys.
Oh!
Yeah, we're getting knocked.
You're getting knocked.
Don't go out.
Don't knock go out.
Let them die.
Yeah, there's literally no reason to kill.
We have two Kp.
Let them fight everything.
We're good.
We're doing it.
We're doing it right now.
We're doing great.
Really phenomenal guys.
They put a barrel on the boat.
I'm still staring first floor just before.
They put a barrel on the roof.
I got it.
I broke it.
I'm about syringes here, I think.
It's fine.
Do you need syringes?
Because I have some.
No, I'm good.
I'm playing.
I have two alt excels for you.
Okay.
Yeah, we're going to need your alt.
I do not.
I am full.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no.
Don't worry.
I've not used my alt once.
Yeah.
There's just a random.
Oh, there's two guys right outside this door.
Yeah.
Just chilling.
You're fine.
We just hold this.
It's fine.
It must be so confused with me staying up here.
I'm on the right side right now.
all good just keep scanning ducky literally just keep
scanning right yeah wait wait wait they're on a roof now
they're on a roof okay okay grab the helm no i have oh wait
you're over there never mind never mind no i have it already
scanning you're just getting a roof in a little bit make
sure there's nobody up there oh you know there's one there's
one up there yeah there's probably someone on the right for
sure yeah definitely there's one up there i see them wait
top five what do we need three top three probably oh maybe a
little bit more to be honest okay it's okay i'm just gonna
look for more kp on the outside we're good yeah there's two
two guys on the outside I mean, the zone's gonna end right
in front of us.
We're good right now.
Yeah, the whole team on the roof and then and then there's a
team on that door.
Okay.
Do we try to grab roof and then buckle?
No, no, they're on roof.
They're on roof.
There's a full three man in this costume here.
How do we get out of here?
We're gonna jump down and go left.
That's it.
Okay.
Once I just stand up there, I'm gonna break barrels out of
here.
One sec.
Step there.
Oh, this is nerve wracking.
We're going to jump down and go left on the staircase.
Right here.
There's that one rat.
There's a rat right here.
We can just rush that rat and then we could get in three
kills.
You're gonna have to jump out and play this fucking fence
line over here on the left side, okay?
We're gonna have a smoke where they just ulti are.
I don't know, he sees me.
It's okay.
We need this team to die on the right, bro.
This team down below on us is really fucking us, to be
honest.
Right here?
Yeah, this team is fucking us, but it's gonna be really hard
to do anything.
They're right here.
They're putting barrels on us.
They're trying to trap us inside.
They're gonna probably call StiglDS here late game.
They'll be smart if they did.
What balcony?
Yeah, no, yeah, tell me you need to start bringing these
barrels outside.
They're putting barrels on your balcony.
You need to do it.
I can't.
It's on the outside.
I'm left.
Far left.
Just walk out, peek on the outside.
Right the barrels.
Nice.
That's your job.
We just jump out of your left side late.
So let's see what these guys do.
They have to leave before us.
Let's see what these guys do.
I'm playing my life.
No matter what.
Okay.
Me too.
We stay alive here.
Good ulti.
Or grenade.
Can you scan underneath us and see what they are on the left
side?
I don't know.
It's still there.
Okay.
So yeah, stay inside late.
Stay inside late.
We're going to swing out left.
We're going to cost you all these kids too late.
Right side.
Okay.
Play here slow.
Need them on the right side.
Oh, just kill them on the right.
Okay.
All right.
Kill these kids.
Kill them.
Top three with four kills.
I don't know.
11 points.
We needed to do that.
That was our only play.
I have no idea if it's enough or not.
11 points is a lot of points.
Oh my god, I have no idea.
I have no idea.
It's gonna be so close.
That was our only play.
That was...
Okay.
Oh my god.
That was so stressful.
That was a miracle play.
No!
One point.
fucking kidding me wait oh my god wait is it are we actually
one
we got one more point we would have tied 10th place but we
win the tiebreaker oh Oh my God.
That's so hard, Frankie.
VG's, man.
It's all good.
Hey, listen, listen, we did a good job.
We did a good job.
Oh my God.
Dude, that was the one, man.
That was the fucking one, bro.
We even tempo your calculations.
No, tempo.
No, tempo was low key.
Almost right, though.
Yeah.
I mean, that was the, we really only just needed to get a
fucking snag of KP somewhere else.
Where are we going to look at?
You know what I mean?
Yeah, there was no way.
We're so broke.
and the the 10th place team will will randomly what did 10th
place get last game oh they got like oh oh no they got they
got three points last game if we get griefed last game we
quote oh my god we have grieved so high i can't believe they
got rid of the content team but wait wait better though we
did better we did better we always next year.
Yeah, I'll see you guys next year.
All right, we'll return.
What is the next one?
Is it after split one playoffs?
Actually.
When's the next one?
Yeah, yeah, it would be after.
It would be like whenever so land is May.
Okay.
And then split one would start somewhere around the end of
May or early June.
So I guess that would be when it is.
End of May or early June is when CC1 should be.
Okay.
because they have a pro league qualifiers next week oh my
god i can't believe it we were so close we're literally one
point no i'm so bad we win the tiebreaker off of that too oh
my god we did one more kp bro oh we did so good you guys did
so good dropping down we got the oh my god we got both kp
too yeah no we got it all we got both that those kills there
was no way we could get third Yeah.
There's no way we can even get third place there.
We're just dead.
Yeah, there's no way.
No, we did get third place.
That's the thing.
I mean, I mean, second, my bad, my bad.
Yeah, it was the only way.
There's no way we could have got like second place.
I can't believe it.
If we didn't get grief last game, remember those names,
remember those names last game that creep.
That's on you.
Remember those.
I will write those names in my death, death note book.
Well, end game, end game.
End game.
that we're not writing any names in anything like that
because we missed like maybe one or two kp on that team
fighting in that show we got two of them but there's like
one more we could have got yeah the stars were aligning to
oh my god what a heartbreaker oh shit we're improving we're
improving i'll see you guys next challenge i get a lot i had
a lot of fun this week though that was good that was fun one
month break and then we run it back yeah oh i'm so down you
know the lives if we make it past day one you're all proud
of us i'll be that was that was actually way big improvement
though yeah we improved so much i feel like we should have
been able to get that type of game every game okay so here's
the thing though we're gonna ruin valcon 99 of the time okay
if we're on storm point two then yes if we avoid all the
bullshit bro we just we just get top threes like we just
literally because i could call zones teams won't feed you
inside feed face inside of a house because it's hard to push
the cost like we just need to avoid the the really sketchy
spots i guess at all costs like you can think there's a
slight chance a dumb team will push you guess what that team
is done and they are exactly yeah so like now we know though
like we just need to play inside spots where they there's
just no way they push us yeah we need to play costing and
just get inside we can't be pinched anyway or nothing yeah
there's like no they'll fucking run out of yeah pretty
pretty fucking evident i guess all right we got we're
getting better next challenge is circuit you guys see us in
round three we're gonna make it What did they get this game?
It must have got a lot of points.
They died in, they died in 10th with zero.
Oh my God.
If they died in 11th, one more place earlier.
That actually is unbelievable.
All right.
Well, we improved.
I'm happy we improved though.
We got better.
I'm so proud of us.
We got so much better.
And we didn't have like some team that's purposely griefing
us.
We landed.
That was good.
Lightning Rod and Siphon too.
Yeah.
over a bit we're improving on our pois we're improving here
we're improving also we looked like to be honest we looked
way more locked in this week like breaking barrel or putting
barrels down we just looked like way better yeah getting
kills yeah yeah exactly i think we did good i'm proud of us
regardless we're running back though next one right yeah
yeah 100 100 i'm so down i'm so down you don't have no make
my liquid media guys make my yeah where's my Yeah, but
actually, yeah.
We need a, we all need, we need a liquidakedia too.
Yeah, we're official.
We're official.
We're an official team signed by TSM.
Yeah, low key sexist, she doesn't have one yet.
I don't want to say it.
Wait a minute.
We took out, wait, wait a minute.
We took off the 10.
Yeah, no, no, no.
And then we got let go by TSM cause we failed.
We've got it.
We only get signed while we're playing.
And then we got let go in between.
Yeah, we got let go cause we didn't make it.
So we're free agents now.
We're free agents.
Look, it's so good.
It's okay.
Next challenge is circuit.
we're going to run it back yes 100 i wonder what the meta
will be then who knows what's saying yeah yeah okay we'll
stick with this i don't know we are not i don't know we
might need this constant blood all the time okay it's okay
that's why we're like we're not going to do the nh trap
where after one bad tournament we break up no no no no we're
yeah i mean that means we're staying together for every
rivals too right yeah okay um yeah yeah i mean it's If I
need to win money one month to pay a mortgage, I'm sorry
about that.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, every, I mean, it's, yeah, all right,
this Twitch rivals might be random.
We don't know that.
This Twitch rivals was an anomaly.
Every other Twitch rivals we played, we've been like middle
of the pack.
We've done one.
What do you mean?
Every other, this is our, that last one was our second.
What is this data pool?
We have two Twitch rivals together.
I remember playing like four Twitch rivals and i kept
getting in the middle i played one two twitch rivals with
you guys not four yeah i might have played two i might have
played two without you yeah probably done better than the
two with us oh yeah so so donkey was the one that was like
oh no what do you mean money's on the line we play someone
else but i plays better oh whoa whoa wow i've placed higher
definitely before i've I think Doki has more earnings than
TEPO.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure.
My liquipedia is out there.
I definitely have more.
All right, that's it.
Liquipedia.
I don't have a liquipedia.
That's the thing.
Wait, don't what?
I don't have one because they removed it.
Not even under.
Oh, wait, they removed it.
They got removed.
They removed it because they were like, there's not.
So you had one, but then they removed it.
Yeah, because they were like, it's not, the tournaments
aren't official enough.
So they removed my liquipedia.
Yeah, but they still don't make it.
for me the moderators hate me because i'm an anime girl
money from an official tournament that means we have to that
means we have to get into pro league and then get i
literally win more money in unofficial tournaments for sure
you definitely do without a unofficial apex turn i can
unofficial apex tournaments pay more than a without a doubt
oh 100 100 that's your show right i deserve it ggs guys
though all right ggs though i love you all man i love you
guys so much thanks for playing i appreciate i know i'm not
the best but i appreciate y'all for hanging out no you were
great igl you did great got us into the zone every single
time thank you we try by the way i i bet i bet 50 lunches on
that zone poll last time i just you guys my mic just cut out
and you guys just didn't hear it i'm just gonna say the fact
that we did better than nine other teams who scrim a lot
together and who like do this for a living like i feel like
you know don't you don't you plays the game once a week yeah
that's when we play this i think i play less than anybody
else yeah we literally don't even scrim and we did better
than like nine other teams that's on them that's no we did
so good that was that was pretty good worst part about that
if that's a trio down below and we kill them we win that's
yeah which sucks yeah it's coming up it's coming up where we
jumped off no oh no they're gonna be like no all right ggs
though guys ggs i love y'all man i'm gonna go talk to my
chat and cry i love you guys a little bit 10 minute delay
i'll see you guys later oh yeah i love y'all oh my god we're
so class but um uh we already played apex for like four
hours now so happy we did really well.
I feel like we're improving more and more as a team.
And it's like our character arc.
Each challenger circuit you see us get better and better.
So you're here for the journey.
You're gonna see us in round three next challenger circuit,
which is like what, in like two to three months or
something.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
Next challenger circuit.
It is a character arc.
You're here for the besties journey.
We're gonna have the revenge revenge arc.
I believe in us.
Anyway, thank you guys as always for supporting us and for
watching watching me I always always do appreciate it I have
so much fun just hanging out with the besties I love just
you know even though like you know, it's a competitive
thing.
I just do have fun Do have fun just hanging out and like
talking shit With the besties because it's like our hangout
session It's not just like a competitive tournament.
It's literally a hangout session too But yes, thank you
Dragoons as always everybody Stay hydrated, posture check,
get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.